Monal S: Hey, guys!
Monal S: Good evening, good morning, guys. Hello, hello, hello, hi. How's everyone?
Monal S: I hope everyone is doing fine.
Monal S: Waiting for tomorrow's weekend, because in weekend we learn here. And tomorrow is, again, weekend here in India, at least. Yep.
Monal S: In India. Good morning, guys. Good morning, good morning, good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Monal S: Yes, guys, I'm doing good, I'm doing fine.
Monal S: Thanks for asking. No winter there. Guys, winter is here, but in Bangalore, we don't get a crazy winter.
Monal S: It's mild, it's good, it's enjoyable.
Monal S: Yes, okay.
Monal S: Morning, guys, good morning.
Monal S: Next Wednesday, we don't have class, yes. Don't worry, you will get an official mail, but unofficially, you already know that there is no class.
Monal S: Yes, Mayank we will have.
Monal S: But just from basic Python, the projects which we can create is very simple. It's not really helpful in the resume. Once we get into the stats part, once we do EDA, feature engineering, and the database projects as well, then we will learn more.
Monal S: Yes, guys, I had breakfast, but…
Monal S: I will have more in the break. It's like Karachi of Pakistan. Yes, I'm not sure…
Monal S: What is the weather in Karachi, right here?
Monal S: No, not… not idly guys. I had protein.
Monal S: They're taking shifts.
Monal S: Trying to reduce weight.
Monal S: Good morning, good morning guys, good morning.
Monal S: Secretivios.
Monal S: I'm too, Bangalore, that's great. Yes, nice cool weather. It is, it is, windy outside, windy a little bit.
Monal S: cool outside, but in home, it's fine. It is good.
Monal S: Today, I'm connecting by mobile due to I'm going to village. It's findable.
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Revised yesterday lectures? Yes, great, guys.
Monal S: You should always revise yesterday's lecture, all the lectures. If you're not confident in one of the lectures, just revise it.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Here in Gujarat, it's sizzling code. Sizzling code, alright? That's good.
Monal S: Good morning, guys, good morning. It's crazy, minus 28!
Monal S: Even my refrigerator is not giving minus 28. That's awesome.
Monal S: I'm not sure whether it is awesome or not. I know for people outside, it looks good, but you will not be even able to go outside, right? It is minus 28.
Monal S: It's not…
Monal S: Yeah, hello, hello, good morning guys, good morning. Today's my first class. Hey, Rajiv, welcome to the course, thanks for joining.
Monal S: what I understood is loops for… loops for a dictionary need a lot of practice. Yes, guys, even, for now, what we will do, we will start… we will not differentiate the groups. What we will say? We will say that for people, who have not…
Monal S: Maybe kind of a politically correct answer, but,
Monal S: Because sometimes people feel demotivated, right? Yes, hey Vishnu, welcome to the class, thanks for joining.
Monal S: Class I will start in 2 minutes, okay? 2 minutes.
Monal S: So, yes, so whatever topics which we are starting recently, this loops, dictionary, list, it requires a lot of practice, because you might forget it, and
Monal S: There are a lot of things to remember now.
Monal S: So… Keep doing practice. I think this week will be good for practice, yes, guys.
Monal S: The weekdays which are coming is good for practice, right? We don't have classes, not learning a lot of things, so you guys can keep on practicing.
Monal S: I have gone through some recording, not all earliest UTMA providers. Guys.
Monal S: Rajiv?
Monal S: We'll talk about Udemy later. Enjoying the clouds, it's getting the heat now. Yes, yes. Alright.
Monal S: No class on Wednesday.
Monal S: office work, guys, I also have office work. I cannot skip from that.
Monal S: That's true, okay? So, let me start sharing my screen. Then, for people who are new, as I told you, 2 minutes, but still, I can introduce you a few things, okay?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So, this is our learn.krishnaacademy.com for people who joined recently, and for people, again, who kind of forget it. So, if you go to, courses, and look for
Monal S: the courses you are enrolled in, okay? You will not see all of this, you will only see Data Science 2.0. If you click here, you will see three sections, Get Started. These are all the playlists which Krishna has provided, so someone who wants to do Fast Track can do it. Someone who's interested in live session.
Monal S: whoever has attended live session, they are interested, alright? So, they can watch these live sessions, these are recorded versions. Once today's class gets recorded, it will also… you can see a new section here as well. I have added one more section that is miscellaneous, that is,
Monal S: I will talk about it, okay? If you click here, if you click on this link, okay? If you click here, if you click on this link, you will see something like this, okay? You will not see all of this, because I am the admin of this, but…
Monal S: This is something which I'm providing, so you all can get everything in a single place, but make sure that you read it. Here, I've specifically mentioned that it is only active while I am teaching you, okay? Because this is… I'm not paying for this, this is a free resource. So, just…
Monal S: While I'm teaching, I just want everything to be in a single place. So I've added a few things as requested by other people. You can see on the announcement, in the announcement, we have seen that this is an upcoming holiday. This is not a national holiday or something. This is just holiday, which I am giving, because this is…
Monal S: Batch, currently, I am teaching Data Science Batch 2.0. You can see holiday, you can see upcoming class agenda, that is today's class agenda I've already mentioned here. Whatever LinkedIn post I personally feel that people ask, right? What is the roadmap, what is the PC configuration, you can just read about it. This is not, like, a rule I've given, but just a good read if you want to do that. This is about announcement.
Monal S: If you… this is about announcement, and again, read everything before asking me anything, okay? Then there is one FAQ section. In FAQ, I've also added timeline for modules, because people were requesting how many times it will take for Python and other things, right?
Monal S: Yes, Sharvan, see this.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: This is the timeline, I can… I can… I have already mentioned that note, the above, the below breakdown, okay? Let me write.
Monal S: The below breakdown is an approximate estimate based on the class conducted in Batch 1. This is not about Batch 2, okay? It is intended only to provide a high-level understanding of the time and class distribution across the modules.
Monal S: This should not be considered as a representation of how current or future batches will be structured, so this is just to give you an idea. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear what I just mentioned? So, before considering everything, I have mentioned note all over the place, because this is something I'm providing, it is not a part that it is mentioned in the syllabus or something.
Monal S: Okay? We are here to learn, we are not here to fast track. If anyone wants to go fast track, all the playlists are here. You guys also provided the Batch 1 recordings as well, yes?
Monal S: So, if anyone wants to do more, wants to do, crazy, okay, you can follow that. But this is something which we got in the previous one. Obviously, the time will be less, because the syllabus is a little different, okay? We are focusing more on the agents parts in this particular course, and reduce few things which might not be necessary in future. So, you will see less classes, but also you can see we have Wednesday classes as well, right?
Monal S: So, guys, again, if you ask anything more detailed at where we are, where we are not.
Monal S: That is not a part of today's agenda, alright? Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Aruna, we will do that. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: So, added all the things, now no one should have any doubt. Yes? Clear? Alright.
Monal S: So, let me close this and bring it here. Alright. So, great introduction to the class.
Monal S: And everyone know where we have… yes.
Monal S: Sure.
Monal S: Welcome, Anna. Okay.
Monal S: So, this is 25 Sundays, and I will be giving you assignment as well, because I told you yesterday, on Sundays, we will be getting assignments, we'll talk about that later. But in today's class, we'll be talking about string methods. I know that some people might feel like that, we have learned strings, then again, why we're learning strings. What I'm doing is, I'm kind of keeping in every class, I'm kind of keeping few easy things.
Monal S: Plus.
Monal S: complex things as we move on. Functions, functions, loop, right? So we are increasing the complexity, not just class by class, but in a class, we are starting from easy to hard, because it is what keeps us engaged, right? If I always start from the hard part, and if we always learn the… if I introduce 10 methods of string in a single class, it might be very overwhelming at the start.
Monal S: So, we are moving…
Monal S: We are increasing the complexity within the class by introducing few simple things, then the hard things, alright? So, string methods we'll be learning, then while loop, you already covered one type of loop, but again, we'll be giving you introductions.
Monal S: And functions, we're talking about, a lot of you already know Python pre-defined functions, print and other things, but here, now we will learn how to create our own functions, alright? Guys, for any queries regarding the syllabus or something, please refer the syllabus, okay? Yes, it will be covered, in short, Abhinav. But if you want to know more details, you can cover there, okay?
Monal S: Abhinav?
Monal S: Then, functional arguments, we will also see that, okay? We have already seen function arguments, but we'll talk about that later. And if time requires, I will give you more things, I will teach you more things. Otherwise, we will close that class today. Alright? Is everyone clear with today's agenda?
Monal S: Everyone, so whoever is not interested in learning all of this, they already know it, they are… feel free to drop off today's class and enjoy your weekend. If you're someone who wants to learn things again, then let's get started. Okay? Great, great.
Monal S: Good energy, everyone, my voice is clear, screen is visible, everyone is having good energy, then we can start class.
Monal S: Yes? Awesome.
Monal S: Yes, let's go!
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: string.
Monal S: Let's talk about… String Methods.
Monal S: Okay? We have already… we have already, learned few of the string methods. Tell me, guys, which of the string methods which we have learned if my string is hello.
Monal S: What is one method which we have learned till now? Strip.
Monal S: We have also learned L strip, R strip.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Dream and something which we have not learned remand something, alright? So, these three are the methods, methods of string, which we have already covered. Now, I will cover a few more, okay?
Monal S: It is very, very, very simple, and I think in practical, it will be faster. So you can see I've created one notebook file. Everyone knows how we follow the structure in the class.
Monal S: In every class, we don't have to repeat it, that's why we have created it like this. So the first topic which we are learning is string methods.
Monal S: Everyone, it does not require explanation, it is not a concept, it is just a matter, so see carefully, okay?
Monal S: Focus.
Monal S: Let me close this as well. This is looking good now.
Monal S: Okay, so let me just give you an example, that is… Let's write,
Monal S: value. String value. I'm just writing str value 1.
Monal S: big variable name, but I will write data science.
Monal S: Alright? This is data science. Now, what I want to do, you can see this data science, has some uppercase and some lowercase. When we have capital, it is uppercase. When we have lower, it is lowercase, alright? Now, this is string. If I want to make… see, again, this issue is happening, okay?
Monal S: Maybe I need to do something with my VSCO.
Monal S: I will quickly start it.
Monal S: Just wait.
Monal S: Yesterday's class, it was happening.
Monal S: It should work.
Monal S: Just wait, let me first run it. Okay, it is working.
Monal S: Let me reshare now.
Monal S: Can you disable class? Yes. Thank you for reminding. Disable chat.
Monal S: Guys, chat is disabled, okay? Now focus. Thank you.
Monal S: Okay? So, this is, data science.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: And what I want to do.
Monal S: Now, I will take this string and see the method which I am going to apply. Now, I want to make all the characters present in this string to uppercase.
Monal S: just like this, D is uppercase, S is uppercase, I want to make everything as uppercase. So what I will be doing, I will be using a special method called as upper.
Monal S: dot upper.
Monal S: You can see it is already giving us suggestions. If I run it, you can see all of them are…
Monal S: uppercase now, okay? So currently, it is not saved. If you want to save this, if I print it, see this? This is uppercase. But if I print the main value, it is still the case in the original case, right? If I want to save it, that is what I've told you, how to save things. Again, we have to…
Monal S: paste, this will create a new value. This new value will again reinitialize this value to create the final.
Monal S: updated variable. So this variable is now updated, alright? I'm not going to update the variable again and again, because
Monal S: again, wasting unnecessary time, alright? So now what I'm doing, let's run it, let's delete this.
Monal S: And I'm keeping this in comments.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Done. This is one of the methods. The first method is upper. Now, let's talk about the next method. Similar like upper, we have lower.
Monal S: it will convert everything to lowercase. You can see, previously the data science was looking like this, now it is data science, all in lowercases, alright? Now…
Monal S: Let's talk about one of the use cases. Let me talk about STR title, okay? If I talk about title of any person or any word, title means the first character should be capital, other should be small.
Monal S: That's what title says, okay? So, every… in every word, the first character should be
Monal S: Capital. Here, if I give you an example, let me write it as… data, Signs.
Monal S: is fun, alright? This is the string. Now, in this string, if I want to make it as a title, okay, if you want to make it title, it means D should be capital, S should be capital, I should be capital, F should be capital. The first character of each and every word in a sentence should be capital, and that's what title does.
Monal S: So, if I want to do the same, I will write the variable
Monal S: And I will just mention dot title.
Monal S: So now…
Monal S: The first character of each and every word in a sentence is capital, alright? This is pretty simple.
Monal S: So now, let's talk about if I don't want to make each and every word, each and every character of a word capital, I just only want the first one, then again, there is a
Monal S: another method from the string. So let's do that. Here, there is a string title that is called as capitalized. You can see, this is title. If I want to just capitalize the first word and the first character only.
Monal S: Only the D will be capital, others are still small. That is capitalized. Alright? These are just fun things.
Monal S: Now, there is something like…
Monal S: This is just for fun, I personally don't use it, but it might be a case where you will find this useful as well, okay? So, for an example, let me write…
Monal S: string…
Monal S: value 2. I'm just creating a variable, and in this string, let's suppose everything we asked from the user, user just provided us the inverted,
Monal S: Case, alright? Let's suppose I want to write hello.
Monal S: And instead of writing like this, user have written H-E-L-L-O.
Monal S: You can see, this looks weird, alright? This looks weird. So everything should be opposite of what user provided. H is small, H should be capital. ELLO is capital, it should be lowercase. So if you want to do the same, we can use something like this.
Monal S: This is called as swipe, okay? Swipe case.
Monal S: So, advocates.
Monal S: Now you can see, it is fixed. So only if you have certain cases like this and you want fixing, then you will use it. Why we are learning all of the string methods? Because when we are going into the machine learning part, we are going to work with a lot of data.
Monal S: And data sometimes… data always needs to be fixed to the certain category, certain requirement, alright? So, if this is our requirement to always convert that to lowercase, we will convert it, alright? And I will also show you, while creating the functions.
Monal S: That, converting the data to the standard. Let's suppose everyone is providing their name in different, different cases.
Monal S: How can we make sure that our function or our program works always?
Monal S: to always convert into standard method. I either always convert to upper, either always convert to lower to make it work always, alright? This was happening in our… whatever application we use, right? This is what happens. If you have seen that, it also happens in Gmail. If you write something like this, let's suppose your email address is ASDFGH,
Monal S: at the rate, gmail.com.
Monal S: Let's suppose this is your email. Even if you write A capital and the other parts still same, your email works
Monal S: Yes, our email still works, even if you write all of them as capital, A, S, D, F, G,
Monal S: H. J.
Monal S: it still works. It does not give you a different, it does not give you an error, because
Monal S: At the end, they might be using .lower always.
Monal S: Whatever user provided, always do the lower, or they might be using upper always.
Monal S: Whatever is the requirement, they might be using that. So, whatever you will provide, it will be converted to a standardized value, alright? So, this is the use cases of string methods. So, let me…
Monal S: Convert to standard format.
Monal S: Okay? And instead of Python, I will select Markdown, so it will be provided as a notes.
Monal S: Usage example.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: All are same email.
Monal S: Okay? Better. This is our notes. Now, there is one important thing that we need, two more important things, okay? We have seen that
Monal S: Where is that? Strip, right? We have seen strip, so let me write, if we have something like this, str value.
Monal S: STR value 3.
Monal S: And if you have something like this, data.
Monal S: And if we use a strip.
Monal S: The strip will remove the spaces.
Monal S: the trailing spaces, trailing from left side, or left side… or right side, it will remove the spaces. You can see now we have data. Now, there are a few more important things which we are going to use a lot. So, let me create another value.
Monal S: And let's suppose, in this value, user have written their data in a string. Let's suppose I have written my date of birth, I have written my name. I have written my date of birth. I have written my phone number.
Monal S: I've returned my phone number and email.
Monal S: Okay? And email. So what I've done, you can see, right now, I've just mentioned name, but here, my name will be present, my date of birth, my phone number, my email. You can see what is one character that is separating all of these values.
Monal S: Okay? I just want to know your answer, so chat is enabled. What is one value that is separating these four values?
Monal S: name, date of birth, phone number, and email. Yes, comma is that one value, okay? Comma is that one value which is separating this four value. Now, if I want to extract my name, let's write my name now, okay? Let's write my name as…
Monal S: I wanna… Let's write some date of birth.
Monal S: in different format. So let's write… Just random values.
Monal S: Suppose this is my data upload.
Monal S: 1870. I'm a regular, okay? Then some phone number…
Monal S: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, and some email. Email at the rate gmail.com. Now, it looks more familiar, yes, this looks more familiar. Now, if user provided input like this.
Monal S: How are we going to extract the name? How are we going to extract the date of birth? How are we going to extract the phone number? How are we going to extract their email? So, there is one good method provided by a string that is called as split.
Monal S: Okay? Split. A split function… If you mention that in this string, you want to split by what?
Monal S: You want to split by what? Guys, tell me, you want this string to split by what?
Monal S: Comma. So, in double quotes, I will write the character comma. So, this will see, in this string, we have to look for comma to separate the values. Now, see the output when I run it.
Monal S: Guess, is this usable now? Is this better than before?
Monal S: So, a split is a method which provides you list as an output. So, what you will do, now you will save it as user list.
Monal S: My user list is saved, you can do whatever you want with the user list. Cool?
Monal S: Is this a cool method? I personally like a split a lot. It is very useful.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So, split is going to split this string
Monal S: via the common thing. You can see, if I split this STR value by comma, monol will be separated, this value will be separated, this will be separated, this will be separated, because all of them is separated by this comma.
Monal S: Yes? Are we clear, everyone?
Monal S: Are we clear? If the comma is not present, are we even able to understand which one is email or something?
Monal S: Yes, there is no separation now, so we can't do anything.
Monal S: This is a wrong data, but you can see if there is even a space in between.
Monal S: If there is even a space in between, I can mention space here. Let's run it.
Monal S: It still works.
Monal S: It still works, because we are giving it that split by space.
Monal S: If I give split by slash, this forward slash, what will happen?
Monal S: Monol 12 is the first index, 01 is second, 1870 is third, this is 0, this is 1, this is second index.
Monal S: This whole thing is second index. You can see, this whole thing is second index.
Monal S: If you don't use anything, if you don't use anything, space is by default.
Monal S: A space is a by default value. Are we clear?
Monal S: This is called a separator, SEP.
Monal S: This is the hidden argument which we need to mention. If you don't write separator.
Monal S: Whatever we write is going to be a part of separator, okay? So for now, just consider that this is separator.
Monal S: Is everyone clear? Can I… can we move forward? So let me write… The comma, because… comma… is good.
Monal S: So, if you write… if you write space comma, then it will be an issue, because there is no space comma. If I run it, let's see.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: It has not separated because we told it to separate by space comma. There is no space comma here. So make sure that you are doing exactly what you want from here, okay? There is no space comma. Whatever is present, it will do that.
Monal S: Duh.
Monal S: Okay? So now, next part.
Monal S: I don't understand the separator part that you are typing. Komal, what part do you… you don't understand? Tell me.
Monal S: Don't, don't worry about separator.
Monal S: Com… Komal?
Monal S: Don't worry about separator.
Monal S: Think of this as, when you pass this thing, it is a default value of this particular method is space.
Monal S: Right now, you're passing comma.
Monal S: See why you can use that, okay?
Monal S: Komal, don't worry about it. Okay, guys, I hope everyone is clear, then I'm disabling the chat and moving forward. Okay? Disabling the chat and moving forward.
Monal S: Okay? Great.
Monal S: do all the permutation combination, guys, later, okay? Great. So this is about split. Split does this, okay? Now, there are a few more things on the string, that is…
Monal S: in this string, in this string, if I want to know, if I want to know,
Monal S: Just wait, okay?
Monal S: If I want to know at which index in the string, as I mentioned, a string is consisting of characters. Are we able to iterate over characters? String? Yes. We can iterate over a string just like a list, so it means it also has an index. If I want to know the index of at the rate.
Monal S: Alright, so I will use a function called as find, and I will write at the rate.
Monal S: So, it will return us what is the index of the at the rate. If you want to validate it, let's first find M, okay? M.
Monal S: M is present at index 0? Yes. M is present at index 0.
Monal S: we are able to see the same. If I write… let me write this string here, so we will know what we are doing, just in our comments. We don't have to go…
Monal S: To the top again.
Monal S: Now, if I try to find Z,
Monal S: Is there any Z present here in this particular string? No. So, when you type something which is not a part of the string, it will give you minus 1. So, minus 1, whenever the output is minus 1, you just need to remember that. Minus 1 means
Monal S: If minus 1, means…
Monal S: Character is not present in the string.
Monal S: Alright? So, you can pass string, you can also pass words here as well, so let me show you about words.
Monal S: Same function, same method, okay? Now I want to find monog.
Monal S: Monol starts with, so it gives you the start index of monol. So, let's talk about 12.
Monal S: Start index. 12 starts from 6. Let's see. 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5… Yes.
Monal S: from 6th index, 12 starts. So, it gives you the start index of where these particular words is occurring in this particular string.
Monal S: Alright, this is about fine. So you guys can do, again, all those permutation combinations later, but this is also a very useful one, okay?
Monal S: Now, let's talk about the next one. We have done the split, which is very important. Strip is done, find is done. Final thing, okay? Final thing, which you guys can use it for in assignment, and in production also, we use it. That is called as…
Monal S: join. So, let's suppose you have some data in list, okay? You have some data in list.
Monal S: You have something like name, Do you have something like…
Monal S: Place, you have something like phone number.
Monal S: That's all. Okay? In this list, you have different strings. So, you have different words.
Monal S: Alright? Now, what you want to do, you want to merge all of them directly. You want to merge all of them directly. And you can do it. There is one behavior of a string that, if you provide string plus another string.
Monal S: If you do string plus another string, it joins the string. We have seen that in the same behavior in the print.
Monal S: When we do print of name, comma place, it will join that, right? Similarly, you can add a string, it will not do addition. When you add a string, this particular operation is called as…
Monal S: concatenation.
Monal S: Okay? This is called as concatenation, but when we perform addition, this is just addition. So here, plus works. When we do 1 plus 1, it does addition. When we do string plus string, it just joins to string.
Monal S: Just to, just the behavior I'm telling, okay? So, if I want to have name, place, and phone number, all the words present in the list, I can do one thing. We have learned for loop, yes? So, what I can do?
Monal S: what I can do?
Monal S: I can create this for loop for I in words. Then what I can do?
Monal S: I can just keep adding new words. So, I'm creating final word.
Monal S: I'm creating final word as empty first, okay? I'm initializing a empty. Then what I will do, I will keep adding… in this final word, I will keep adding the I. What will have… I will have… I will have word one by one.
Monal S: So, if I add I and print the final word.
Monal S: and print the final word, I will see all of them attest.
Monal S: Yes, all of them are attached. Even if I add a new value, list will be able to work through it. So, if I add, let's suppose, yes, just a simple num… word, okay?
Monal S: And if I use this particular code, you can see, yes, also works. But for this small task, I'm using the for loop. Yes, for this small task, I'm using the for loop, and I don't want to use it.
Monal S: String provides you similar thing, okay? I will tell you.
Monal S: So, to solve this efficiently, so to solve this efficiently, we use something like this. We already have this one, we already have words, this is how words look like. Now, let's use something called as JOIN, okay? So, if I use…
Monal S: dot join. This is string, guys. This is empty string.join.
Monal S: What I want to join, I want to join all the words present here.
Monal S: Yes, very simple.
Monal S: Now, if you… if you write space here, see the behavior.
Monal S: So, what join does, whatever separator you mention here, first of all, I want empty separator, it means between these words, I don't want to have any space. It will join without space.
Monal S: If I pass space here, it means between these words, between these words, when I'm doing concatenation, I want space in between. You can see, now, name…
Monal S: place, and this one has a space. It does not add a space at the end and at the start. It only adds space between. It only adds a separator. If you write comma.
Monal S: it will add comma. If you write comma space, it will add comma space. If you write 123, it will join these words with 1, 2, 3 in between. You can see 1, 2, 3, 1, 2, 3. So, this is what join does. You can use join like this, or save it into a new string.
Monal S: Final word output.
Monal S: You can save it like this.
Monal S: You can see, now the value's changed.
Monal S: Alright? So, this completes all the required… guys, a string can have more things, right? But what we are trying to do here, we are trying to learn the things which is important for us to use in future, in data science, data analytics, and other things. Alright? So, let me first mark this as green, then we will move forward to the next part.
Monal S: I taught more than I thought, because I've only…
Monal S: I only thought that I will be teaching you 3-4 more methods, but I end up teaching how many? 1…
Monal S: I've also shown you this.
Monal S: This… 1, 2… 3, 4… 5, 6, 7, 8, 9. 9 we have done.
Monal S: Okay? So let me enable the chat, and then ask queries. Is everyone clear with this, guys? Is this very simple?
Monal S: Very simple.
Monal S: Sir, please explain, guys, think of this as your assignment.
Monal S: this plus… I know what you're… you guys are confused with this, but think of this as… write your pen and paper and understand what we are trying to do.
Monal S: How many of you will be able to do it?
Monal S: I can explain it, but I know you guys can do it as well.
Monal S: I have written it to show you, but no one will show you that… that while comparing this, we can do that.
Monal S: Okay? Understanding is your part.
Monal S: This is not something which… I have just given that. To do this simple thing, you have to write this code.
Monal S: To do this simple thing, you have to write this code, so try to understand this code, okay?
Monal S: Clear?
Monal S: Indexing is not clear, guys, index.
Monal S: If I create a string like this.
Monal S: if I create a string, like, this is my string.
Monal S: Tell me the… tell me the index of M. Everyone, tell me the index of M.
Monal S: Index of M is 0. Tell me the index of L…
Monal S: Tell me the index of L.
Monal S: Minus 1 is also correct, and 4 is also correct.
Monal S: Tell me the starting index of NAL.
Monal S: If this is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4. Starting index is 2.
Monal S: This is what that particular method is doing. Same exact thing, nothing different is present. See, where is that?
Monal S: I am currently… where is Find? Yeah.
Monal S: Z.
Monal S: Where is Z? Is Z present? No. It means minus 1. Find 12. What is the starting index of 12? Monol is completing in 4th index, then 5.
Monal S: At 6th index, 12th is starting. So, this is why it is giving us 6th. Is this part clear now?
Monal S: Is this part clear now?
Monal S: Why the find giving minus 1?
Monal S: Guys, Surya, is Zed present here in this string?
Monal S: Surya, is that present in the string?
Monal S: Create is giving us minus 1.
Monal S: Now, guys, when we talk about index.
Monal S: See, I always tell you that when you're creating something, when you're creating something as a developer, when you're creating something as a developer, a code or something, you always want to follow a standard.
Monal S: you always want to follow a standard, alright? So this particular method of find, what happens if it gives you minus 2, minus 4?
Monal S: M, if I talk about M, if I talk about M, M is 0. M is also what? M is minus 5.
Monal S: How Python… do you… do you want, when you… when you write find of M, will it provide 0 or minus 5? Does it make sense?
Monal S: Is it a standard? Is it a standard?
Monal S: Do you think that this is a standard that provides multiple outputs for a single thing?
Monal S: So, when we learn lists, it is up to developers that they want to access. It is up to us what we want to access. But here, we are working with a functionality, functionality which we are using, so we want to make it the standard.
Monal S: So, that's why it is working in this direction only. Are we clear? It is working in this direction only.
Monal S: I understood that, but when I ask to find a character which is not present… Surya, that's what I'm saying. Minus 1 means… the meaning of minus 1 itself is not found.
Monal S: Surya, are we clear?
Monal S: When you work with find, the meaning of minus one itself is not found. That is what this function is saying. When you're going to create, soon we are… in this class, we are going to create our own function. You will understand that we can provide whatever we want. When you learn… when we go to the machine learning and something, usually what we will do
Monal S: We ask model, machine learning model, right now we don't know model. We ask machine learning provide to some output.
Monal S: Alright? Machine learning to provide some output.
Monal S: But what happens if machine learning did not provide any output? No output.
Monal S: No output.
Monal S: There are some systems which always require the feedback from the system.
Monal S: When the system will ask for the output, machine learning can provide it. But when the system asks model for the output, and no output is provided, then this will become error, because system always requires something. Then, in that case, what we can do?
Monal S: We can always provide that if no output, just give me minus 1.
Monal S: So, this system will not break. Later, we will learn that this is all in high level, okay? Is everyone having a clear understanding what I'm trying to say?
Monal S: Guys, later we'll talk about your doubts on whatever experiment you are doing, okay? Experiment part we'll cover at the end.
Monal S: Okay? Now, some people are asking, that is a good question, that…
Monal S: This print and join are same.
Monal S: Print and join are same? No. Guys, in print, in print, if I write something like name, and place…
Monal S: and phone number… First, understand the use case of print. Guys, tell me what print is used for.
Monal S: What print is used for? Print is a function which is used to see the output. Does print… does print has capability to change the string?
Monal S: Does print has capability to change the string variable name?
Monal S: Does JOIN have that capability?
Monal S: Does JOIN provide the capability?
Monal S: So, this is just to show us, this is for visualization purpose. If I print it, you can see, by default, it is space. If I write separator is equals to comma.
Monal S: I am just visualizing. It is not changing the value, I cannot save it.
Monal S: I cannot save to a variable.
Monal S: Okay? This variable is saved, but print does not gives you that, okay? We'll talk about it. Print is not… see this. Is it giving you anything? No.
Monal S: No.
Monal S: So, print is different.
Monal S: Let me write, not same as join.
Monal S: Only used for… Visualization.
Monal S: Guys, loops code, I will copy. You… this is thing… I will provide this notebook, but don't worry about it. Right now, we are not… you guys need to practice a lot. I will give you assignment, then you will practice your loops and other things. I have just given you an example that with all of these codes, we will see that. Alright. So, are we ready to do… are we ready for the next part?
Monal S: Guys, are we ready for the next part?
Monal S: Yes? Correct.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Don't worry, between every topic, we will do discussion like this.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Next topic.
Monal S: while loop.
Monal S: Let me first write loops.
Monal S: Abhinav, raise your hand at the end, we'll teach you again, okay?
Monal S: Guys, that is disabled, okay? So, there are two loops which I told you, which we'll be learning. One we have already learned is called as for. One is while loop.
Monal S: Okay? Let me talk about when to use for, and how while loop is different from for loop, okay? For loop is used when you need to iterate, when you need to iterate over a sequence of elements.
Monal S: over a… sequence of elements. We have seen how for loop does it.
Monal S: Yes, we have seen how Forloop does it.
Monal S: Example… for I in our list.
Monal S: 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: Then we will do something with that I. This is what first for is used for, okay? Second is…
Monal S: We already have
Monal S: We already know… How many iterations?
Monal S: We already know how many iterations
Monal S: Loops is… Going to take.
Monal S: Right? If I talk about how many iteration loop is going to take, if I have 3 values, it means 3 iteration. So we already know here, yes? If I don't know the list.
Monal S: list is having some thousand elements, then still I know. I can just use length of this list, and it will provide me how many elements we have. So, when we have already a predefined,
Monal S: counts of values, then we'll be using for loop. We know exactly that when it is going to end. We don't need to know, but we know that if requires, we know that
Monal S: how much time it is going to take, how much loop it is going to take, how much iteration it is going to take. Alright? This is about for loop.
Monal S: Now, let's talk about while loop.
Monal S: Okay? While loop is a little different.
Monal S: So, we use while loop when…
Monal S: We want to repeat a block of code.
Monal S: And we want to repeat our… Block of code.
Monal S: Until…
Monal S: 17… Condition is true.
Monal S: Okay? So, if we want to repeat certain code until certain condition is true, then we will use while loop. I will give you an example.
Monal S: Okay? I will give you an example. First of all, this is… let me write the syntax. This is how we use while loop. While…
Monal S: True.
Monal S: This is, at the end, it should be true, then we do something.
Monal S: Or either the condition should be true, while some condition we will write, until the condition is true, this condition is true, we will do something.
Monal S: Once the condition is false, while loop will come out of it. So here, do we know until when the condition is true? We might not know the answer. I will tell you what does it mean, okay? I will tell you what does it mean.
Monal S: So think of an example that…
Monal S: While, and let me write the condition first.
Monal S: Condition. Condition is…
Monal S: Not the student.
Monal S: Let me give you a real-world example.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Just give me a second.
Monal S: Condition is…
Monal S: Suppose the condition is to understand, condition is to understand or learn… yes, understand Python.
Monal S: Condition is to understand Python.
Monal S: Okay, just giving a real-world example. Real-world, what we face daily. So, condition is to understand Python. So, what we will write…
Monal S: If… Just wait, my screen went black, now it comes.
Monal S: If the condition, it means if my students are able to understand, then I will… Jump to next topic.
Monal S: Then I will jump to…
Monal S: Next topic. This is for me, this is my while condition. While this condition, if students are able to understand Python, then I will jump to the next topic. If students are not able to understand, then I will not go to the next topic. So, until they are able to understand, I will keep on jumping, keep on jumping.
Monal S: Alright, I will keep on jumping. So, for the simple example, I will tell you in terms of what we were doing. So, let me write while loop, okay?
Monal S: Let me write, while loop. So see this? This time, what I want, until… Until user writes Hello!
Monal S: We will keep on taking input.
Monal S: From user, and print it.
Monal S: So what I'm saying… guys, read it again. Until user writes hello.
Monal S: We will keep on taking input from user and print it. Now see what I'm doing. Just see the behavior, don't see the code, okay? I will say…
Monal S: First of all, I will initialize user input as empty.
Monal S: Then I will tell while loop that
Monal S: While user input. So, is userInput equals to hello?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: It is not hello. Then what we will do…
Monal S: See the execution? I will tell you, don't worry. It might confuse you at the start, but it will be good.
Monal S: Enter your input.
Monal S: And we will save it back to user input.
Monal S: And we will print user input. Now see the behavior. Don't see the code, guys. Don't see the code, see the behavior. When I run this particular file, you will see input on top of my screen, so… look at there.
Monal S: Code is… Running. Okay, code did not run.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: it will run now, okay? See, I have to provide input. I have mentioned ASD.
Monal S: It is printing, but are you able to see that it is still running?
Monal S: Now, if I provide you name Rudra.
Monal S: Ruther printed, but it is still running, you can see it is still running. Now, if I provide you someone's name, FFCS1, this is one student's name.
Monal S: Still working. So, do we know when it is going to stop? No, we don't have the count that when it is going to stop. It totally depends on this particular condition. Now, if I write hello.
Monal S: Now, if I write hello, then this condition will be false. Is user input hello not equals to hello?
Monal S: Incorrect. Hello is equals to hello. That's why this loop is broken, and we are able to see that this loop is stopped after printing it.
Monal S: Yes? So, this part is done. So, don't worry about the code, but now I'm enabling the chat. Is everyone able to understand the use case of while?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand the use case of while? Don't worry about the code, code, I will explain. Use case of while loop.
Monal S: It's a loop, guys.
Monal S: Someone asked, it's totally fine, difference between if and Y.
Monal S: If is a control flow, if checks for something, okay? Guys, if checks for something, and then provide the code. If has nothing to do with the condition, conditional is also… I can write condition without if loop as well, without if control flow, see this.
Monal S: If I write something like this…
Monal S: User input string is not equals to help, this is a condition without if. What if enables… if enables us that once condition is due, do something.
Monal S: But if does not have a flexibility to loop through it, right? But here, we are able to loop through it until the condition is true. Once the condition becomes false, it will come out of this area and start executing code which is written here.
Monal S: Let me write. After while loop.
Monal S: Okay? After a while loop. Let me run it again, you can see, now if I just write hello as the first word.
Monal S: It will break.
Monal S: And it will come after the loop.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: clear.
Monal S: Where are you providing input, guys?
Monal S: Where am I providing input? On the top, are you able to see everyone?
Monal S: On the top, are you able to see? Don't worry, I'm not yet executing the code. While loop takes time. Is everyone able to see the top screen?
Monal S: Hello, good morning, Lugna.
Monal S: Alright? So now, let's see some condition.
Monal S: Guys, there is a meaning to everything, why it works, why it doesn't. We'll tell you later, but let's get started, alright?
Monal S: So, let's start with the simplest example. Are we ready or not? Guys, if you're not ready.
Monal S: Send a message to the user until… That's great, yes.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand why the main structure of while loop
Monal S: Then I will continue and explain the code, different code, with a different example.
Monal S: There is no if code. I'm disabling, okay? Everyone see now. You will understand. People who were not able to understand before now understand, you will be able to understand. So, let's write the syntax.
Monal S: syntax of while loop. This is what while loop does. While… here we write some kind of a condition, but it… only if the condition is true.
Monal S: Only if condition is true, we do something.
Monal S: Whatever we want to do, we do something.
Monal S: So let's start with an example. Very simple example.
Monal S: Okay? At the start, my count is equals to 0.
Monal S: At the start, my count is equals to 0. Now, what I want to do, let me write in hash, so we know that it is a comment, okay?
Monal S: Until the…
Monal S: Keep adding plus 1 to the count.
Monal S: Until… It is…
Monal S: The smaller than… Or… equal to… 5.
Monal S: So, it means what? This is the condition. Our condition should be, from this statement, what we will… we have concluded, our condition should be…
Monal S: Count should be smaller than or equals to 5.
Monal S: Now, I will only enable the chat to ask you whether you are able to understand the problem statement or not.
Monal S: Tell me.
Monal S: Only this part, don't ask me anything else. Are we able to understand this part, what we want to do?
Monal S: That's great.
Monal S: Now I'm disabling it, okay?
Monal S: Great. Thanks for…
Monal S: being interactive in the course, while now we will write the condition. While count is smaller than or equals to 5, we will do something.
Monal S: We will do something. But at the start, our count is equal to 0.
Monal S: anywhere in this code, nowhere in this code, we are incrementing the value of count. But what we will do, we will do it here. So, we will write this code like COUNT
Monal S: is equals to…
Monal S: count plus 1. Or for people who wants to make it short, this is the same exact code, COUNT plus equals to 1. I'm commenting it for now.
Monal S: Okay? This is the main code which I have written. Now let's see one by one, everyone. Okay? For while loop to work, whatever condition we are applying, that variable has to exist before.
Monal S: If that variable does not exist before, like here, we will not be able to work with it. Python will say, I don't know that variable. So always make sure that whenever you are working with while loop, whatever variable you are using.
Monal S: Whatever variable you are using, you have already initialized it before. Now, let's talk about iteration one by one.
Monal S: First iteration. Everyone, first iteration. The value of count is equals to zero. This is where we started. Now, while loop condition. Let's see the condition. What is the answer of this condition? COND. Let's answer the condition. Is 0
Monal S: Smaller than or equals to 5? True.
Monal S: 0 smaller than or equals to 5.
Monal S: True.
Monal S: If it is true, we will do something.
Monal S: Now, what we are doing here, we are incrementing the count. So, in the same sentence, in the same iteration, what we are doing, the count value will be… the count value will be 1.
Monal S: Once the count is 1, is there more statements? No.
Monal S: we will go. Because the condition is not false yet. Second iteration.
Monal S: What we will do.
Monal S: What is the value of count? Because now, we will not go here on the top, we are in the loop. So, now we will check this condition. What is the condition saying? 1 is smaller than or equal to 5. Now, see, we are comparing with 1, because the count value has become 1. We have incremented the count.
Monal S: Now, what we will do? This is true. Once it is true, we will go inside and do something. What we are doing, we are incrementing the count.
Monal S: Count will be plus 1 from the previous number, it will be 2.
Monal S: Done.
Monal S: Do we have any more lines of code? No. Let's go on top.
Monal S: Again, third iteration, we will see count.
Monal S: 2 is smaller than a request to find, then again, the same thing happens all the way.
Monal S: Suppose now the count value is… okay, let me do one by one, because people will get confused.
Monal S: Again, the condition.
Monal S: 3 is smaller than equals to 5, true, then we will increment the value of count to 4. Yes? Now we will see, on the condition.
Monal S: 4 is smaller than equals to 5.
Monal S: True. Again, we will increment the count. Now the count value is 5. In the next iteration, we will compare, is 5 smaller than or equal to 5?
Monal S: 5 is not smaller than 5, but 5 is equals to 5. It is still true. We will go inside, then increment the count.
Monal S: Okay? Then increment the count. Now, the count is incremented.
Monal S: Now the count is incremented. Now let's go to the condition. What is condition saying? Is count 6 smaller than and equals to 5?
Monal S: No, it is false. We will not even go inside, we will go out of the loop.
Monal S: In the same level as while loop.
Monal S: in the same level as the while loop, because while loop has ended, right? We will jump here, whatever the code is written here, we will execute that. If nothing is written, we will not execute anything. But, you can see, what was the last value of count?
Monal S: What was the last value of count? 6.
Monal S: So, if we print, let's suppose in the same level of while, if we print the count, even though this condition got, false, is smaller than a request to 5, the count value is 6 because
Monal S: Once it was 6 here, then only it becomes false. That's why the count value is 6.
Monal S: So now, only ask the question if you have doubt here. Don't ask me to repeat, guys, I have done this… see, this is what we call it as dry run.
Monal S: Dry run. Dry run means take your notes, take your pen and paper, and do the coding step by step. Then only you will understand why something is working, why something is not. Alright? Enabling the chat, and let me know if you're able to understand it or not.
Monal S: Everyone? Is everyone able to understand the while loop? Very simple.
Monal S: Very simple, clear, awesome.
Monal S: Okay? Explanation is very clear, that's great, guys. Okay?
Monal S: While loop is not doing extra run, guys. It is not doing extra run. Here, what we are doing, to make it false, we need to… we need to do something here.
Monal S: We need to do something here, okay?
Monal S: Guys, you can do while and while, you can do for and for, just like, as I mentioned, programming languages does not care if you write, if you write thousand levels of if also.
Monal S: If you write thousand levels of if also, programming languages doesn't care. What it cares it, it will break down all of the steps, and it will just execute it.
Monal S: Alright? Simply, if you have while loop and some condition, you can again manage another while loop, whatever you want.
Monal S: Whatever you want. So guys, if you want to create an infinite while loop, what you will do? While true, and you will do something.
Monal S: This will be infinite.
Monal S: Okay? This will be an infinite loop, it will never stop.
Monal S: You can create it, there are use cases of it, but now we need to learn how to stop something.
Monal S: Is everyone clear now?
Monal S: But the example shows print hello. Guys.
Monal S: I'm giving you 2 minutes to understand why it is printing hello. I'm giving you 2 minutes, just look at the code, and understand why we are getting hello.
Monal S: Just a hint that it is the same concept like we were getting 6.
Monal S: We were getting user value as 6. It's the same concept.
Monal S: Look at the screen. No!
Monal S: Okay, I will tell you why we are getting hello. Everyone, see the code.
Monal S: I know at the start.
Monal S: It is my responsibility to help, so I will do that, okay? No, guys, see?
Monal S: Let's see, again, this is how we do dry run. Dry run is something which we should also learn. It's not a part of syllabus, no one will teach you dry run, but it is something that is helpful to me, okay? At the… everyone see this? I'm disabling the chat.
Monal S: Correct, correct, Lamshit.
Monal S: What is user input? At the start, it is empty.
Monal S: It is empty. I'm just writing single quotes, it is easy here when I'm writing, okay? Is empty quotes, let's talk about the condition.
Monal S: Let's talk about the condition. Empty codes… Not equals to hello?
Monal S: It is capital H, but same thing, right?
Monal S: Is empty codes not capital to hello? Yes, they are not capital.
Monal S: It means it is true. If it is true, then we are taking input from the user.
Monal S: See this? We are not taking input from the user, then going inside. We are checking the condition, then going inside to take the input. Now, here, if user write, here, if user write, hello, what will happen?
Monal S: Hello will go to… hello will go to user input.
Monal S: variable.
Monal S: In this variable, if you write, hello, it will go to user input. What we are doing next? What we are doing next? Print.
Monal S: They will print.
Monal S: the hello, whatever user mentioned. In our case, we are printing hello. So, hello is present here.
Monal S: Now, this is a part of while loop. This is indentation.
Monal S: This part is done, coding is done, now it will go back.
Monal S: What is user input?
Monal S: Hello. Hello not equals to hello?
Monal S: False. Hello is equals to hello. So, this will be false. So, you have already seen… you have already seen printed hello in your terminal. Now, what you will see, once it is false, it will not go inside. What it will do, it will print while.
Monal S: Next statement is, print after while loop.
Monal S: So, guys, coding will not be mysterious. Everything happens for a reason, because we are the developers, we are the one who is writing codes. Enabling the chat, let me know if everyone is able to understand this. Guys.
Monal S: Are we able to understand why hello was written?
Monal S: Everyone clear?
Monal S: So, hello is not after the while loop. Hello is when we are taking the input, then we are printing it.
Monal S: That's why we are able to see hello, okay? If you want to fix that, what you can do, you can just print the user input before, but user input does not even exist before, so first time it will print empty.
Monal S: it will print empty string, but it will not print hello, because after input, we are checking the condition. So it will not print hello, but it will print empty. Is everyone able to understand what I'm trying to say?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand what I'm trying to say? If I switch print and user statements.
Monal S: This one will be printing empty string first, but it will never print hello, because we are taking input as the last statement in the while area.
Monal S: Why it is not printing others? Because at the first time, I only written a hello.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: I will write HE.
Monal S: I will write H-E-L.
Monal S: I will write, Rahul.
Monal S: I will write monol.
Monal S: However, at RK.
Monal S: I will write hello.
Monal S: Done. Hello is not printed, but you can see empty string is printed at the very start.
Monal S: Why you take empty input? Because at the start, I want to take an empty input. Rodra.
Monal S: I am the developer, it is totally up to me. But, if you don't take anything, if you don't take anything.
Monal S: If I command this code, what will happen, guys?
Monal S: If I comment this code, what will happen?
Monal S: While does not even know user input.
Monal S: So we need to provide it something.
Monal S: Are we clear now?
Monal S: This value will not even exist, then the comparison will not exist.
Monal S: Nothing naught equals to hello, what does it even mean?
Monal S: It should be existing in the RAM, alright? So that's why user input.
Monal S: So hell, it will not happen. We have created this course like that, this particular batch, okay?
Monal S: Toyota, I told you, right?
Monal S: This one is having one extra classes, and also the syllabus is different. Are we clear?
Monal S: Guys, you can assign whatever you want. It is also a variable.
Monal S: You can do… here, you can also assign a variable. It's totally up to you what you want to do.
Monal S: Okay, great. So, this is while loop. So, we have covered while loop. Now, what I wanted to tell you, the next thing, guys, the next thing which we want to learn…
Monal S: is a part of control flow again. Control flow is not just about if and else. Control flow is about controlling the flow or execution flow, right? So let me write control flow.
Monal S: Control flow, next. So there are some keywords. What happens? Let's suppose I'm running things in for loop.
Monal S: Okay? For, and then I have written the condition of the for loop. Here, it requires an iterator, or a list of… or groups of values, alright? So, for condition, then I will do something. So let's suppose, in this condition, here I have
Monal S: 100 values.
Monal S: Here, I have 100 values. 4 will it rate how many times? Guys, tell me 4 will it rate how many times?
Monal S: If I have 100 values, 4 will iterate 100 times.
Monal S: 100 times, it will run whatever is written inside this. Now, suppose for certain values, out of these hundred values, for certain values, let's suppose these are names, these are 100 names. For certain values, like monol, I don't want to run any of this written here.
Monal S: Okay? I don't want to run any of this written here, I want to skip whatever is written here. So even though there are 100, it will run 100 times, but it will skip all of this. So let me give you an example. Okay? Let me give you an example.
Monal S: Say this. Again.
Monal S: Control flow.
Monal S: Correct. So what I'm doing, I'm first creating names, okay? Let me write names of Sudarshan.
Monal S: Okay? Then let me write Praveen.
Monal S: Then, who else? Khabijit?
Monal S: Sandeep?
Monal S: And in between, I want to write normal.
Monal S: I can write Gaurav, but for now, let's keep it like this. So, I have written few names here, okay? And now I want to iterate over all of them and do something with them. So, let's…
Monal S: do it for… and I can use anything, right? I can use I, I can use N, whatever I want. For name in names, no, it should not confuse you guys. Very simple. For name in names, I want to do…
Monal S: name.
Monal S: Capitalize.
Monal S: And then, save it back to name.
Monal S: Once it is done, then what I want to do, I want to do more.
Monal S: name.upper. I know it does not make sense to capitalize and then upper, but I'm just doing certain operations. I'm just telling you that we are doing certain operations. Then I want to print name.
Monal S: Is this code clear to everyone?
Monal S: Now, suppose I want to break this execution flow. I don't want all of these things to run when the name is monol. Is everyone clear on the goal?
Monal S: I don't want to run all of these three statements only when the name variable is monol.
Monal S: So, there is a word called continue, which breaks the flow. So, what I will do, say this.
Monal S: What I will do, I will write something like, if name. First, I need to check when monol is coming. If name is equals to monol.
Monal S: Then, I will write a special keyword called as continue.
Monal S: So now, see the execution? You will not see Mona, let's see.
Monal S: Are we… are we able to see Monal?
Monal S: Are we able to see Monal?
Monal S: we are not able to see. So let me show you how the execution works like. Yes, it skipped monol.
Monal S: Everyone, see this.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So, names will come one by one. Names will come one by one.
Monal S: And, first, what we are doing, we are checking from this, if the name, let's suppose A, is equals to
Monal S: Monol.
Monal S: This condition is false, so we will not do something, whatever is written inside, if. So what we will do, we will go to the next step in the same level. In the same level, what is the next code?
Monal S: We are doing something.
Monal S: Something. I'm just writing something.
Monal S: Again, we are doing something.
Monal S: So, once this is false, we will keep on doing something.
Monal S: Now, let's suppose, instead of this A, the name actually is Monal.
Monal S: The name actually is Munal. Now tell me what is the condition? Is this… is this true or false?
Monal S: Is this true or false?
Monal S: Is monol is equals to monol, is this true? It is true.
Monal S: It is true. So what we are doing, in this code, I have written continue.
Monal S: I have written, continue.
Monal S: Whenever Python sees continue, and continue should always be present in a loop. Continue, if you just write plain if else, continue will not work. For continue to work, it should be a part of loop, either for loop or while loop, it will work anywhere, okay? Whenever Python will see continue, what it will do?
Monal S: Whenever Python will see continue, it will not execute whatever is written below, it will directly go to the for loop.
Monal S: So, when the name was monol.
Monal S: We checked if name is monol.
Monal S: it was true, Python saw continue, then, instead of going to the next line of code, it will directly go to the for loop for the next part. Now, whatever is the next name will come.
Monal S: whatever is the next name will come here, then if name is not monol, then this will be false, Python will keep on executing it. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: So, continue kind of skips whatever is written below, it directly goes to the next stage, that is, again, taking value from the for loop. That's what continue does.
Monal S: Clear.
Monal S: Are we clear, everyone?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Next, there is another statement, final statement on the control flow called as break.
Monal S: break, think of break as a brother or sister of continue. Continue, if continue skips the
Monal S: coding part, break… break… breaks the loop itself. So, whenever we see monol, whatever is written below it, it will not execute, but it will also not execute anything that is after monol.
Monal S: Okay? That is, after monol.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Okay? So… Briggs?
Monal S: Terminates the loop itself.
Monal S: Loop will work perfectly fine before this condition is, true. That is, before break, everything that is written before, it will keep on working like that. But whenever it sees break, the for loop is done.
Monal S: it will come out of the for loop, and whatever is written in the for loop, it will do that. If I talk about continue.
Monal S: What Continue does?
Monal S: Escapes the current iteration.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: It escapes the current iteration.
Monal S: Guys, break… I also told you, right? Dry run, you guys… how many of you will be able to do the dry run as well of break?
Monal S: C.
Monal S: When A will come, see this? When A will come, it will do the coding, because A is not equals to monol. It will work as it is. It will run all the code.
Monal S: Run below core.
Monal S: Let's suppose next is B.
Monal S: it will run the below code as well. Same thing.
Monal S: When it sees Monal, When it says monol, What happens?
Monal S: What happens? The condition is true.
Monal S: the conditions became true. What we do in true? We have a break keyword. Once Python will see the break keyword, what it will do? Break will tell Python
Monal S: Gum… out of loop.
Monal S: And done.
Monal S: So, if you see in the coding part, instead of this monol, you can see, after monol, we have Sandeep. So, Sandeep is written here, because it just skips monol. Whenever it sees monol, it skips whatever is present here, it will directly go to the 4 part.
Monal S: Now, instead of this continue, if I write break, what will happen?
Monal S: If I write break, what will happen? Will we see Sandeep?
Monal S: Will we see Sandeep?
Monal S: Will we see Sandev? No. Will we see all of them? Will we see all these 3 people?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Are we clear now between break and continue? Very simple.
Monal S: Very simple.
Monal S: Break and while loop are like, no, guys, break is control flow, while is a loop.
Monal S: Break and continue task is to control the flow of the for loop based on certain conditions.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Now, let me tell you that while looper.
Monal S: As I mentioned, while loop, we can create an infinite loop by.
Monal S: Manish, dry run is something which I'm doing here, these notes which I'm creating. Dry run is running the code one by one using your pen and paper. Are we clear?
Monal S: Yes, correct mom, okay? So, how to create infinite? I can just write true, because condition also, Python just checked true or false. Boolean, right? So, if I just write true, it will always be true. So here, if I write print.
Monal S: Hello. What will happen now if I run it? Hello will keep on printing infinitely. Yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: Tell me! Hello will keep on printing infinitely. So what I will do, because guys, if something is running infinitely, our system will break, okay? Memory will crash.
Monal S: But latest Python and others handle this, so what I will do, I am initializing count is equals to 0. See what I'm doing, guys? I'm not going to explain the logic. I'm already explaining it. Count is equals to 0. Here, what I will do, count plus equals to 1.
Monal S: and I will write… If… count is greater than 100. If count is smaller than 100, break.
Monal S: Is this now infinite loop? Is this infinite now?
Monal S: It is not infinite.
Monal S: Then, original nature of while true is infinite, but because of break, that is a control flow, we are able to move from the
Monal S: While infinite loop.
Monal S: Raj Kamal? No, it does not.
Monal S: So, this is infinite.
Monal S: This is infinite.
Monal S: But this is giving us control to exit, Based on condition.
Monal S: Condition we have written.
Monal S: So…
Monal S: I have written it, I have ran it, but for some… just wait. While it is true, yes, it is true.
Monal S: Count is smaller, okay.
Monal S: Count is… okay, it should be count greater than, guys. Because if count is smaller than, then it will not even work. For 0, it will break and turn. Yes? So, see this? The best way to debug is to add more print statement. We will do start
Monal S: And then, after a while loop is done, we will write ANDL.
Monal S: better. Now see what happens if I make it as smaller than 100.
Monal S: Start and end. It did not even run for one time, because 0 is smaller than 100 true, Rick.
Monal S: Now, if I write greater than 100, Then it will break.
Monal S: On this hello.
Monal S: Okay? Instead of hello, if you just want to print the count value, you can also count, you can also print the count value. So, if you print the count value, then you will see when exactly it is breaking. You can see, on 100, it is breaking, because when the count value is 101, this condition will be false.
Monal S: It will come to the true… it will come to the while loop, but it will break here.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Count will be 101, it will still come here, but it will move out of the loop from this particular statement.
Monal S: So, it will run 101 times guide is, it will run more than 101. You can see, we are starting from 0.
Monal S: If we are starting from 1, then we can say it will run 101 times, and it will end on 101th time.
Monal S: But this time, when we start from 0, it will run 102 times.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: No, return is different, we will learn. Return is also present here.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So, is everyone confident in while loop now? At least you know the concept, when to use while, when to use for.
Monal S: Guys, do dry run. Loops, you cannot learn until and unless you do dry run or do practice. If you understand the concept, take a note of it, do dry run.
Monal S: If you're afraid of loops, don't even learn anything new.
Monal S: I'm talking about in this 5 days we have time, right? If you're afraid of Luke, don't learn anything new.
Monal S: Loops are the main foundation of coding that will give you things, guys.
Monal S: If you want assignments, are you able to see assignments?
Monal S: I've also given the solution, but solution I will not give now. Solution, I might provide on Friday and Thursday. This is just… and because in coding, when we talk about it, you can do a different coding, I can do a different coding. This is just a simple solution. But you can see this?
Monal S: I have given 10 assignments. You are free to only work with 1, or complete 10, or complete 3. There is no constraint from my side. But this time, I have also given you expected flow, which will give you a hint. What you… you can look at this hint to understand the assignments.
Monal S: You can see, it uses WHILE, it uses IF-Else, it uses BREAK.
Monal S: This one uses for loop, it uses… whenever you see a new word, don't worry about it at all, okay? Don't use use whatever you want, or skip that question. Later, we can talk about, but make sure that you complete 3. If you complete three, you will feel confident. Are we clear?
Monal S: See, I've added for the functions based on today's class, but let's see how much we are able to complete.
Monal S: The main task is, everyone should be confident in loops. Very, very, very important.
Monal S: Okay? Done.
Monal S: Can't copy text from the chat, guys. You will not be able to copy it. You will provide it… you will be provided with all of this later.
Monal S: Take a snapshot, do coding later, okay?
Monal S: Guys, assignments I will give you later, okay? So, done. We are completed with while loop, and also control flow, which was not even a part of agenda, but it helps us a lot.
Monal S: These two are almost same, but we will learn it.
Monal S: So, let's take a break, yes?
Monal S: Then we will go… If both for while and are used, break will be terminated? Yes, Navid.
Monal S: break will terminate the first loop, whatever is inside. Guys, good question. If I have 4, then something, then another 4 inside this 4, then break. So, this break is a part of this loop, so it will come out of this loop, but still execute whatever is written in the same hierarchy. Good question.
Monal S: Great, Naved.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Rajat, your messages are visible.
Monal S: Guys, I'm not going to debug your code right now. Later.
Monal S: For names is equals to name, for name equals to name, continue.
Monal S: It shows, again.
Monal S: Because you have written names, Ganesh, it should be name.
Monal S: Ganesh, are you clear? Sir, can you please paste code here, input?
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Can you please explain example where, 4 has one… 4 has one more 4 with break?
Monal S: Alec, you can do it!
Monal S: Alig?
Monal S: Guys, I'm doing one more coding.
Monal S: This is names, okay? Let me write…
Monal S: For that, I have to create a different list.
Monal S: Guys, you are not doing your practice, okay, I can see that. If you always say that, write this code, then you're going to practice.
Monal S: I can write the code.
Monal S: But I want all of you to write the code.
Monal S: Are we able to understand?
Monal S: Print I.
Monal S: then I will print the name. So what I'm doing…
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this? Can we write infinite condition using for loop? You can write Sahi Raj. That is… that is why a while loop is made.
Monal S: Okay? Guys, what will happen?
Monal S: In the single print, I am writing all of these people names, yes or no?
Monal S: So when the value of i is equal to 0, I will write all of their name. When the value of i is equal to 2, I will write all of their name again. When the value of i is equal to 3, I will write all of their name again. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Guess?
Monal S: Now, what I will do to make this loop short, I will write if name.
Monal S: Okay? I've not taught you this, but something like IN. In checks whether this value is present inside certain list or not.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Now, if name is present in, guys, there is one thing called in. IN just checks, very simple. If this value is present here or not, if present, it will return true, else it will return false.
Monal S: So… see the output. Then what I will do, I will continue. I will break.
Monal S: If any of the name I will found, if any of the name of here, I will found in this list, I will break from here. Once I will break, but I will still see 1, 2, 3, 4, yes or no.
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: I will see that.
Monal S: Let's run.
Monal S: See, we are seeing only Sudarshan, Sudarshan. Why?
Monal S: It will print the value of i. First name is… first name is Sudarshan. Sudarshan will come here. Sudarshan, is Sudarshan present here? Is Sudarshan present here?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: So, we will print the name Sudarshan. Then, what is the next name? Next name is Praveen.
Monal S: If this statement is true, it will break. Break will do what?
Monal S: Break will break this for loop.
Monal S: After this for loop, what is the next statement? Next statement is, it will go to the for loop print i, so we are able to see 2. Then this whole thing will keep on repeating.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand the output now?
Monal S: Guys, where is Nimes Sudarshan?
Monal S: Rajiv, why it will take last index?
Monal S: This is exclusive, right?
Monal S: Guys, please do it. Nupur, can you tell me what is Jump?
Monal S: Nupur, can you tell me what is Jump?
Monal S: Can you share me the link of Jump?
Monal S: Do we have jump in Python, Nopuru?
Monal S: Napur?
Monal S: Where… in which documentation you have seen jump.
Monal S: Guys, this is a different programming language, not everything gets transferred, translated directly.
Monal S: Okay? In Python, we only have two control flow, break and state, break and continue, we don't have anything else.
Monal S: Yes. Jump is not even a part of Python.
Monal S: Guys, read this code later and understand. Whatever I am doing, I'm clearing someone else doubt. If you're interested, understand all of this.
Monal S: Again, assignment.
Monal S: Pass is not a jump. I'm not sure whether pass and jump are the same, but pass is meant for something else.
Monal S: From where did you get to the ocean?
Monal S: Right? So, I think this is done. I was able to show you nested for loops also, and it's already 10.30, so one and a half hour of learning.
Monal S: of me teaching. Not all of them were learning, but me teaching, okay? So after break, guys, make sure that you clear your minds, because we are doing something amazing. This is where the fun starts. It might be fun at the start or not fun, but this is where we will start our…
Monal S: coding. We have done coding, but this is where we will make it more usable, okay? This is where we will make it more useful. So, this is what we'll be doing. Alright? Is everyone clear now? Everyone happy with today's class?
Monal S: Thank you very much, Anthony.
Monal S: Is everyone happy? Great.
Monal S: Okay, so when the classes are big, I will give you 15 minutes break, fine.
Monal S: 15.
Monal S: We need to cover more things, guys.
Monal S: Guys, when… the faster we are able to complete it, the faster we can close the session as well.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: As you've seen, the class always extends to half an hour, always.
Monal S: So, let me restart the timer, I know.
Monal S: And, once…
Monal S: I will close my video, then only I will start the timer, okay? Yes, guys, be right back, we'll see you after some time. Bye-bye for now.
Monal S: Hey guys, welcome back.
Monal S: I know, still 30 seconds left.
Monal S: Alright, yes, back, I've been back.
Monal S: At breakfast, brunch, lunch, Yes?
Monal S: Feeling refreshed? That's great.
Monal S: Yeah, I also like sunlight.
Monal S: I'm not sure who doesn't like, but there are a few people who does not like.
Monal S: Okay, awesome.
Monal S: Let me clear my screen a bit. There are a lot of things here which I don't want to have.
Monal S: So we have completed 4 while… Yes.
Monal S: Yes, guys, I live in Bangalore.
Monal S: Okay, alright.
Monal S: Let's move to the next topic, or you can say, if I combine the last two topics, which is a part of function itself, into a single, this is the start of last topic of today's class, okay? It will be long, and without this, as I mentioned, you cannot do
Monal S: much of a coding. You can do that, but still, this is the main basic foundation of reusability, okay? So, let's talk about it. Function.
Monal S: Okay? Function. So let me write a definition of a function. So a function is, you can say.
Monal S: Function is… Named… I will talk about why I'm saying name. Function is a named re… usable.
Monal S: block of code. Very simple. Is a named and reusable block of code And… used to perform…
Monal S: Used for a specific task.
Monal S: used for a specific task. We've already seen a few examples of function
Monal S: Yes, we've already seen a few examples of punct function, I'm only going to write few.
Monal S: print.
Monal S: type, yes? So, this is the name of the function print, right? So, that is the named part. Reusable means
Monal S: just by writing print, whatever code is written behind print, we don't have to worry about it. We are able to reuse it again and again, yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no? So this is reusable part, this is…
Monal S: named part of a function. That is, a name itself is the named part.
Monal S: And whenever we are using it multiple times, we don't have to worry about what code is written behind it, but just use it, okay? So that is reusable part. And again, it has a specific task. What is a specific task of this particular print?
Monal S: It is not, like, a universal function. It only does one job, okay?
Monal S: Prints the output.
Monal S: Pain.
Monal S: Terminal, or screen.
Monal S: It is made for terminal, but now you can see that on notebooks and other things, that you're able to see operating screen.
Monal S: So, these are the examples of functions.
Monal S: These are the examples of functions.
Monal S: that are already come… that already comes with Python. So we call them as… 3… defined functions.
Monal S: We are not the one who created this, it comes with Python, some other developers have created it.
Monal S: So, is everyone clear what a function is?
Monal S: Is everyone clear what a function is?
Monal S: Okay? Now there is one concept. In this function, we already know what function is, we already know how to use it, but now we are learning something advanced, that is…
Monal S: User-defined functions.
Monal S: Now, we are going to create our own functions.
Monal S: User-defined functions is what we are going to learn.
Monal S: So, let me first talk about the syntax of how to do it. We already know syntax, what exactly syntax means. Syntax means the basic structure to create something. When we talk about function, okay, to create a function, we need to write a keyword called as DEF.
Monal S: And then…
Monal S: Name of function. You can write whatever name you want, but make sure that you're not reusing the names which are already provided by Python. Something like print. You should not use print because print is already a keyword of Python, we should not be reusing those names.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Then we provide parenthesis.
Monal S: Okay? Closing and open, open and close.
Monal S: Then we write colon, then we write do something.
Monal S: In a similar fashion, print is also made.
Monal S: Think of print as, like, DEF, print.
Monal S: And then, I will talk about what goes in between, but later. For basic function, we don't require it. And then, someone has written that whenever user will provide something like hello or something, we will do all of this operation within it.
Monal S: So, print is also a function like this. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: predefined function.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So let's create the first function, our very first function.
Monal S: And guys, everything in programming should follow that what exactly we are using it for, okay? For the fundamentals, it is fine that A is used to store. We already know what the problem and variable solves. So here, I will write.
Monal S: I want to take… two different… inputs, from user.
Monal S: Two different numerical inputs.
Monal S: Two different numerical inputs from user, And add them.
Monal S: and print them.
Monal S: How many of you will be able to do this particular, job? How many of you can do this?
Monal S: take two different numerical input from user, add them, and print them. I can do it, easy, yes, very easy. So let's talk without Python. Let's talk without function. So what we have to do, people take input from user, we will say.
Monal S: Enter post number.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Then, enter second number.
Monal S: Then I will store this into a value called, let's say, NUM underscore 1.
Monal S: Num one. Number one.
Monal S: Then, number 2.
Monal S: I know what I'm missing, but I will be asking you guys, okay? Input is done, then add it.
Monal S: So… Sum of number.
Monal S: is equals to… num1 plus num2. Guys, tell me, is it going to add numbers?
Monal S: Is it going to add numbers? No, because it is string.
Monal S: So what we will do… End.
Monal S: Or…
Monal S: If I want to really create a calculator, is int the right option, or should I pick a different option?
Monal S: Floor.
Monal S: Float is the best option, because if I provide 12.3, int is going to cut 0.3.
Monal S: Better for calculator.
Monal S: Load.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: And then… I will do the sum, and then print it again. Print.
Monal S: sum of number. Let me pass number 12.3, and then 10.3.
Monal S: 22.6. Done?
Monal S: Done?
Monal S: Now, suppose I want to again take input from the user.
Monal S: I want to, again, take input from the user, or I want to take two more numbers to sum it up.
Monal S: Okay? I want to take two more numbers to sum it up. What can I do?
Monal S: What can I do?
Monal S: I can create a while loop or something, yes, or I will take another input like this, Yes?
Monal S: So, this same code, I have to write it again to do the addition.
Monal S: take another input, but now I have to save it again or do something. So instead of creating all of this code, I can do a better job.
Monal S: Think of this as, like, print. Yes, this is a repetitive task. This is a repetitive task.
Monal S: I have to again take input from the user, add it again, and then print it. In real world, we don't use notebooks. What we use? We use scripts.
Monal S: We use scripts, so I have to either include them in a for loop. There are a lot of lines in a code. This is not really a good block of code. See what I've written about the function? That is a named reusable block of code. Here, I cannot reuse it. I can reuse it by doing copy and paste.
Monal S: But when you work with notebook file, guys, when you work in terminal, will you be able to do copy, paste, and other things?
Monal S: No. So, there is little bit of constraint which we are able to see, okay? So, what we want to do, we want to make this part simple. It is not efficient.
Monal S: We want to make this part simple, so see what I will do now.
Monal S: I will create a function, and I will say, And… Add… two numbers.
Monal S: Bracket. Colon. Then, it comes the area. You can see indentation is there. I will copy and paste all of this.
Monal S: Paste everything here, make sure that the indentations are correct. All of them should follow an indentation. Function is created.
Monal S: This function is created. When I run… when I ran it, is it running? Is it asking me for input?
Monal S: Is it asking me for input? No.
Monal S: Because this part is called as…
Monal S: Function definition. We are creating the definition of the function.
Monal S: So this is just called creating the function. Are we clear that this is… we are not running the function, we are creating it? Next.
Monal S: Let me remove this. Next!
Monal S: What is the name of the function? Just like a print, see this? Name of the function which we created with blank, with this, brackets.
Monal S: When I run this cell, is it running now?
Monal S: Is it running now?
Monal S: Let me add 100 plus 101.23456.
Monal S: This is the integer.
Monal S: Is it working?
Monal S: Do we need to care? If I create a code like this and just send you this function, do you need to worry about the code?
Monal S: You only need to worry about how to use it.
Monal S: User only needs to worry about how to use it. I can again copy and paste. If I know the name of the function, I can do it differently. See this?
Monal S: Used. Used. Do I need to write the code again?
Monal S: Do I need to write and copy and paste all that code again to run it?
Monal S: I ran for the first time, I have its answer. I ran for the second time, I have its answer.
Monal S: So this is our first function which we created.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand that print might be using something like this? This is a Python print, but the actual code is behind it.
Monal S: Bamshi, because this is what we made.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: If you click on the print, see this.
Monal S: I will show you.
Monal S: This is a print function.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Okay, there are a lot of functions, we can go to the definition, but for now, we are not going there, okay?
Monal S: There are a lot of things, so don't worry about it, how to click on that.
Monal S: So let me… Remove it… where is it? Let me minimize the screen.
Monal S: Okay? It's totally up to you how you want to create a function. Let's suppose you want to create a dummy add-to number. New function. This one we will call it as…
Monal S: Dummy, add two numbers. Guys, make sure that your names are also good. Your function should… tells us what this function is about. If it is dummy, then I will mention 2 and 10. Now, I don't need to take input from user.
Monal S: Yes, I don't need to take input from user.
Monal S: Whenever I call dummy, it will always do the same job again and again.
Monal S: This is also a function.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So, we are done with function. Now, let's move to the next part of the function, that is, please show once again, guys, see the code.
Monal S: What code? It is very simple.
Monal S: just enclosed within Enclosed, this is the syntax, everything should be present inside it, that's all.
Monal S: Guys, you can create more functions here in a single block.
Monal S: See, think of this as, like, you are giving the definition, you are creating the definition, and using it whenever you want.
Monal S: Can you please repeat to check predefined function in between? What do you mean ashwani?
Monal S: My code is working fine because you're not printing. If you don't print it, it will not work.
Monal S: Guys, don't do coding side by side, please.
Monal S: Do it in your free time, try to find
Monal S: Something, okay? Whatever the error is. Alright.
Monal S: Guys, don't copy and paste, just take a snapshot. You are developers. What you will do with copy and paste, you guys also have to learn how to type fast. In interview, if they ask you a question, you will be like, A is equal to 2, you will write with a speed of T, R, I, and T.
Monal S: You also have to increase the speed. Take a snapshot and repeat it. Keyboard is also a skill that you have to work with, okay?
Monal S: Alright, done.
Monal S: Let's do more things, okay? Let's create more functions. DEF, let's do…
Monal S: our custom… Spring… Cleaner.
Monal S: Okay? Here, we will take input from user.
Monal S: Enter any text.
Monal S: Everyone see this. Enter any text.
Monal S: And then, we will take input as…
Monal S: Base string. Base means the first base.
Monal S: What we can do?
Monal S: base string.first strip, yes? We can do the strip first.
Monal S: This input that we will get, can we also use it for capitalize better?
Monal S: Or just always use lower.
Monal S: Then… this is… new base string.
Monal S: And then we will print it.
Monal S: So, whatever user will provide, whatever user will provide, this particular function is going to deal with it. Let's see.
Monal S: Something is wrong, because I did not run this. See, when I'm not running it, and when I'm not defining the function and trying to run it, what it will say? Name… this particular function is not defined. Python is not able to find it. So we need to first define it, and then use it.
Monal S: Let's write a lot of spaces.
Monal S: Then write hello, then write lot of spaces again.
Monal S: Working? Yes. Let's again use it.
Monal S: Here, I provided…
Monal S: Let's again use it. Again, lot of spaces, capital H, E, capital LLO, then a space, then I will write lot of things in capital, then I will write mail.smallcolm.
Monal S: This is the input which I have used. Is this a weird input? Yes? Yes, it should not be…
Monal S: present. This is a weird input which I passed. Now, let's press enter.
Monal S: Is this a more standard version? Everything is in a small.
Monal S: Yes? So we created our own cleaning function by using the Python which we have learned.
Monal S: Cool?
Monal S: Yes, is Python cool? Is programming cool?
Monal S: Programming is cool, guys.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Similarly, you can use whatever you want. You can use it like… COUNT is equals to 0.
Monal S: And… see this, count is equal to 0. In the while loop, you will say, while count is…
Monal S: smaller than 5. Run this particular function, and we will increment the cloud. What this code is doing, guys.
Monal S: What this code is doing?
Monal S: Write it, what this code is doing.
Monal S: It will run for… It will run for…
Monal S: First, 0, 1, 2, 3, 4. When the value of count is 5, it will break.
Monal S: So, till 5, it will work. Till 4, it means 5 times it will work. How many times it is? 5 times.
Monal S: Five times it will work.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Space, let's do a lot of these words.
Monal S: Again, it is running. Let's write…
Monal S: Done. Five times. Done.
Monal S: Are we clear how to use functions?
Monal S: Guys, this is just the start of function. Function is a lot of things. Done? Great.
Monal S: Awesome.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: For me, it stopped for one iteration. Anurag, whenever Python is doing something, it means you are asking it to do something.
Monal S: If it is running one time, it means you have written a program to run it for one time.
Monal S: Okay? So make sure to check the loop, and guys.
Monal S: to what is one of the assignments that you guys have to do? Tell me.
Monal S: I have written this line. Tell me what I'm about to say.
Monal S: Tell me what I'm about to say. Correct.
Monal S: this is what everyone should practice, because you are at the start of coding. Writing coding with this, Python will run it. But if you don't know how your code is going to behave, will you be a good developer?
Monal S: Will you be a good developer if you don't know how your code is behaving?
Monal S: So, you should understand, even before running it, you should know, because you guys were able to answer that it would run 5 times. Who told you it will run 5 times? We are able to see in the visualization, but before that, you guys know that it will run 5 times.
Monal S: Because now your guys are understanding coding.
Monal S: So, this is what we have to do, okay? Write all the solutions first in the notes. In the assignment, you can do it for one or two things. Write everything in the notes, then later, once you think that this is the solution, start coding your solution.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Guys, logic is… logic building is very important. Alright.
Monal S: Now, let's talk about our issue. This is our function.
Monal S: We have created a function called as our customStringCleanup, yes?
Monal S: We have created a function called as our custom string cleaner. What it does?
Monal S: What it does… it prints…
Monal S: Clean, version of… It prints clean version of string.
Monal S: Okay? It prints clean version of string.
Monal S: But…
Monal S: if I want to use… if I want to get the clean version of print, guys, if I want to get clean version of print.
Monal S: Will I be able to get clean version?
Monal S: Create an URL. That's awesome.
Monal S: Let's see. I'm running it, and let's print the clean version as well.
Monal S: I am writing everything in caps plus spaces at the end.
Monal S: This is the input which I am using.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: And let me press enter.
Monal S: Where is that version? Just give me a second. Okay.
Monal S: Are we able to see?
Monal S: Guys.
Monal S: This is what it is printed inside, see? This is what it is printed inside, but if I remove this print, are we cleaning the string?
Monal S: When I'm commenting the print, tell me, are we cleaning the string?
Monal S: Are we clearing the string inside it? Yes.
Monal S: Inside this function, we are cleaning the string. Printing is just for visualization. So let's suppose this is our new function, okay? This is our new function. Now I will run it. Now I will run it with the same input. Now let's see whether we will get the answer or not.
Monal S: Is it giving us the clean version?
Monal S: Is it giving us the clean version? No.
Monal S: This is the concept of return, okay? We have created a function. In this function, we are doing some job.
Monal S: Doing some job.
Monal S: It is doing some job, and its task is done. Everyone, Sudarshan, see this. This particular function currently is doing some job.
Monal S: It is cleaning the string. Yes or no, Sudarshan?
Monal S: We are taking input from the user and cleaning the string. Done.
Monal S: Are we doing any printing here?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: Printing is…
Monal S: Does print change the actual output? Does print change the actual string? Print is just for visualization. Print does not change anything. So even if I don't print it, okay, and try to run, is this particular function giving us the cleaned version? No.
Monal S: This particular function is doing some job, and its task is done.
Monal S: This particular function is… Cleaning the… String… inside… 8.
Monal S: That's all it is doing.
Monal S: That's all it is doing. It is cleaning the string inside it. But our target is… our next problem statement is…
Monal S: V… Want to get… We want to get cleaned string.
Monal S: Do you think… are you able to see any instruction other than cleaning the string, that we are asking that function to give us the cleaned version? Are you able to see any instruction asking this function to give us the clean version?
Monal S: We asked it to clean it, but we are not asking it to give us the clean version.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand?
Monal S: Here, in this particular code, is there any code return where we are asking this function, where we are telling this function to give us something back?
Monal S: Tell me, guys… Everyone is very quiet.
Monal S: Only princes I am able to see. Others…
Monal S: There is no code present here. We are just calling the function, giving instruction to the function to clean it. That's all.
Monal S: Now comes the important part.
Monal S: Let me create the new version of this function here.
Monal S: This is, I will call it as, new.
Monal S: Or, at the end, let me add…
Monal S: V1, or V2. This is version 2 of this particular function, just name, okay?
Monal S: Not able to understand Shivangi, you will understand now. Okay?
Monal S: Guys, print… just print things, print… okay.
Monal S: It is code, everyone. This is A.
Monal S: Where is that?
Monal S: It should be small.
Monal S: Is everyone able to see a sorted list?
Monal S: Is everyone able to see sorted list?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Now, if I print a… If I print A, is this sorted?
Monal S: Is this sorted?
Monal S: No. Guys, how it is sorted, 1, 2, 120, it is not sorted.
Monal S: To make A sorted what we have to do, to make A sorted what we have to do.
Monal S: Now, if I print A, is this sorted now?
Monal S: Is this sorted now?
Monal S: So, when I run this function alone.
Monal S: When I run this function alone.
Monal S: Is it changing the actual A? No.
Monal S: Only when we are asking to give us… see what we are doing? We are asking this particular function to sort this A and give back the actual sorted… actual sorted list, which we are going to store into A. So we are the one asking, it is not doing its job automatically.
Monal S: Yes? Is everyone clear?
Monal S: We are asking it to give us the latest, and then we are going to update it.
Monal S: So, we are the one asking for the latest list.
Monal S: Similarly, when we talk about our custom cleaner, here we are asking it to change the string, but anywhere in the code, there is a functionality that it will give us the new string.
Monal S: Redistribute will give us the new string? No. Is everyone clear what I was talking about?
Monal S: Is everyone clear what I was talking about?
Monal S: Guys, print does not give… print is used to just visualize things.
Monal S: So now, see this new, updated code, version V2. We took the input, everyone, we took the input.
Monal S: In a bass string.
Monal S: We are doing something with the base string, and then whatever the answer of this, we are storing into new base string. So this is the correct version.
Monal S: what I want to do?
Monal S: I want to write a keyword called as return this new base string.
Monal S: So what this function will do, this function will do its job once the job is done.
Monal S: it will… it will throw us back this value to catch. So, this is how we should understand it, okay?
Monal S: This is function A. Let's suppose this is function.
Monal S: This is function. Function is doing the job, and this is us, A. What we want, we want to get the latest value of this function. Currently, this function is doing the job, and the function is not giving us back anything. That's why, when we print A in this scenario, we see none.
Monal S: Because the function is not giving us anything.
Monal S: What we want, we want this function to throw something.
Monal S: Whatever we want to throw, we will write it here.
Monal S: Whatever we want to throw, we will write it here. So this function will throw that value, so instead of getting none, we will catch this value in the variable.
Monal S: So, print is a function which does some job. Guys, tell me, does print return anything? I have shown you before in the previous class.
Monal S: You guys are not, again, revising. See this?
Monal S: If I do print of hello.
Monal S: Print task is to print something, but if I capture this new print, And let's see A.
Monal S: Are we able to see anything in the A?
Monal S: Are we able to see anything from the A? Because this is not throwing anything. Print job is to print something.
Monal S: So, this catch and throw, same concept, this is your… Field up.
Monal S: Suppose you're playing, football, cricket, whatever you want. Whoever has the ball, if that person will keep the ball and will not throw to the other person, will that other person is going to receive that ball?
Monal S: No. If that person is going to keep the ball to himself.
Monal S: We cannot even… that other person will never catch it. So, to ca… so…
Monal S: for that ball to be catched by this person, this person needs to throw it, and throw in Python is called as return. So we will say, return this ball, it will throw it. Whoever will catch it, we need to assign A equals to, B equals to, C equals to, this is called as catching part.
Monal S: So, return is doing what, guys?
Monal S: The return is doing what? Tell me.
Monal S: Return is doing what? Return will throw this value.
Monal S: So this function is throwing something.
Monal S: This function is throwing something, we need to catch it.
Monal S: This is our original V1.
Monal S: when I'm writing it like this.
Monal S: It is not throwing anything, that's why when we catch it, we get nothing. Now let's talk about our new function.
Monal S: This time, this is V2.
Monal S: Clean version output V2. We are storing into V2. Let's run it!
Monal S: what is going on? Because I have not…
Monal S: defined it. When I run it, then it will get stored into the memory.
Monal S: Okay? Let's run it now. Now I will write a lot of capital words, lot of spaces, press enter.
Monal S: This function is not throwing the cleaner version, which we are catching in this variable. Then we are printing it.
Monal S: Now that we have this value, we can use it for other things. Yes or no?
Monal S: Yes or no?
Monal S: But, if this function will not throw something and keep it to itself, can we use it for other purpose?
Monal S: Can we use it for other purpose? No. Because, same concept of this person who is keeping the ball. Until this person will throw the ball, other will not do anything with that ball.
Monal S: So, this is what return. Is everyone clear with the return?
Monal S: Is everyone clear with the return?
Monal S: Awesome.
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: So basically, we can use return anywhere in the line of code, guys.
Monal S: Return only works one time.
Monal S: See this?
Monal S: If this person… Is doing some job.
Monal S: Job 1, job 2. Once this person got the ball, got the ball means… Input.
Monal S: Once this person got the ball, now it is up to person, whatever job that person is going to do. Clean the ball.
Monal S: Put the ball,
Monal S: somewhere. Once all the task is done, it needs to send. So whenever we are sending something back, that should be the last statement. If we send something at the very start.
Monal S: If we send something at the very start, will we be able to do more job?
Monal S: Will we be able to do more job? No. Same thing happens here in coding. Say this.
Monal S: Now, let's see very good example of… now that we know return, let's create…
Monal S: Let's create a better add function.
Monal S: Everyone see the code, you will understand this one by one, okay? We are creating DF add.
Monal S: Okay, we are creating DEF add. Again, let's take input from the user. Where is our ad?
Monal S: add two numbers. Let me copy this whole thing, and let's create a version 2 name, okay?
Monal S: V2.
Monal S: This time, instead of printing, we can print also, but we are returning the value of sum.
Monal S: None.
Monal S: Now let's call the function.
Monal S: If I call the function, it is totally fine not to catch it.
Monal S: If you are printing, it is totally fine not to catch it. If we don't want to use the value, it calculates. If we don't want to use the value it calculates, we don't want to catch it. It's totally fine. So, let me run this cell, and let's run 12.3.
Monal S: And 12… 123.
Monal S: It prints something, yes?
Monal S: it prints something, return part, we are also able to see. It prints something, right? But, do we have any variable? We have the sum?
Monal S: Do we have any variable where we have the sum?
Monal S: Any variable we have the latest sum, we don't have. So I will store sum of addition.
Monal S: Now let's run it.
Monal S: 12.3123.
Monal S: This print is coming from this one, or this one. Tell me.
Monal S: This print is coming from the function itself.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: So, if I command this print, what will happen now?
Monal S: Guys, what is config? Just one line of statement. See this? If I run this again, I don't worry, I will repeat it again, okay?
Monal S: And run it now.
Monal S: Now I will write 12.3, 123,
Monal S: Are we able to see any print here?
Monal S: Are we able to see any print here? No.
Monal S: But do we have the sum of values? Do we have the sum of values?
Monal S: Let's run it. Yes, we have.
Monal S: Now it is totally up to us, we can print. But now, see what will happen. If I write return, not at the end, but at any point in… any point in this particular function, what will happen? Python automatically says, kind of grayed out. Are you able to see that the color is dimmed for this particular line?
Monal S: Because our Python and VS Code know that this will never run.
Monal S: we are throwing it. Once we throw something from the function.
Monal S: Whatever is below it, it will never run.
Monal S: Function task is done once it sees return.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: You can also write return again alone, but it will be none. So, we are writing return sum of none.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So, we are doing the job.
Monal S: Throwing the value, whatever we want to do with that value, we can catch it.
Monal S: Say this. Now, I can do what?
Monal S: Everyone, try to see this, okay? Very simple.
Monal S: I am doing addition two numbers V2, plus addition to numbers V2.
Monal S: First, I am running it.
Monal S: Here, I will write 1.
Monal S: plus 2. What will happen?
Monal S: 1 plus 2 is 3.
Monal S: 3 is the answer here. This will be replaced by 3. It is again running. It is running for… this. If I write 1…
Monal S: plus 3,
Monal S: we are getting 7. So, whatever the sum this provided, plus the sum this provided, we are not doing the addition.
Monal S: Just wait, guys, okay?
Monal S: Alright, done.
Monal S: So, how many of you is not able to understand, and what part you're not able to understand? Tell me. I will help you now. How many of you are able to understand this?
Monal S: How many of you are able to understand this?
Monal S: not able to understand, guys, right? What… okay. Now, people who are able to understand, please stop commenting, I just want to see what other people are not able to understand.
Monal S: Okay, others just write what you're not able to understand.
Monal S: So, where will final result will be stored without run? It will be stored inside function, and it is lost.
Monal S: Please remove, return, and explain. Remove, return? Guys.
Monal S: If I remove return, how many of you are not able to understand this?
Monal S: This function, how many of you are not able to understand? Anyone here who is not able to understand this.
Monal S: This function without return.
Monal S: Tell me, whoever is not, I will explain again.
Monal S: Explain again?
Monal S: Guys, this is literally lines of code.
Monal S: That we do in Python? Okay.
Monal S: How many of you are… again, I'm asking, I'm asking in very deeper level, how many of you are not able to understand these three lines of code?
Monal S: Just these 3 lines of code.
Monal S: Okay. People are… some people are confused with print and return. Everyone, whoever wants to take break, guys, I'm again, it will take 10 minutes from you, it is 11.28. In 10 minutes, I'm going to, clear this down, okay? So, it is 11.28 at…
Monal S: 11.38, you guys can come back, okay? But it is not break for people who don't understand.
Monal S: Everyone could… was not clear with print.
Monal S: This is your terminal.
Monal S: Okay? Terminal is where you write code, where you write code, and then you want to see what value it has.
Monal S: See, understand if you don't understand this print. When I do print of 3,
Monal S: We are giving instruction from Python to OS that we want to see whatever is written between it. We are the one who's writing 3, so we know 3. But when we run this command, Python will just write 3 in the terminal.
Monal S: If A is equal to 3, we have written thousand lines of code, maybe in between, we have written A plus equals to 1.
Monal S: If I want to see what is the latest value of A,
Monal S: So, I will use print. Print task is just to show what is the value which we are providing in between these brackets. So, A is what? A is containing address where 3 is stored. A will have…
Monal S: Four.
Monal S: Is this part clear to others?
Monal S: Others means, or in this between break, what I'm asking.
Monal S: So, print task is… Print task is just to see the output.
Monal S: Only task is to see the output.
Monal S: Again, is this clear?
Monal S: Okay, guys, give me a second, I need to pass my phone, okay?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So, now tell me, you guys will write me, what is the task of print?
Monal S: What is the task of print?
Monal S: Tell me!
Monal S: To show output
Monal S: Its task is not to calculate something, or give us something, its task is, it will do its job, and wherever this is the screen, if the screen in our notebook, if this is the code block where we will write, the screen of that code block is below it.
Monal S: If we are working in terminal, when we write print, the screen is that black screen itself. So, the job of print is to provide output in the output place.
Monal S: in console. Are we clear? That is print's job. Now, I have given you one example where I've written 20023.
Monal S: Okay? When I do sorted off this particular list.
Monal S: if this list is L. If I do sorted of this L, the sort function task is to…
Monal S: Sort the list, Okay? Sort the given list.
Monal S: And store the… New sorted list, New sorted list.
Monal S: in our variable.
Monal S: Say this, very important. This is the task of sort.
Monal S: Sort the given list, and store.
Monal S: Where it is storing? Store the new sorted list in a different variable. Inside it. It is happening, all of the… it is happening inside it.
Monal S: And second task is… Return the new variable.
Monal S: It has two jobs. Does the sorting, store into a new variable, and then return it. So, if I just write sorted of L,
Monal S: Tell me, is it going to change the actual L?
Monal S: Is it going to change the actual L?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: Actual L is still that old value which we have written here.
Monal S: Actual value, actual L is still the same.
Monal S: To make the new… To make the new sorted list, what we should do?
Monal S: We should take whatever this one is throwing us, and save it back to, again, L.
Monal S: So this air will now be… 2, 300, 200.
Monal S: Because we are trying to save the output that this particular function provides. Is this part clear?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: If this sorted function, everyone, if this sorted function will not do the second job.
Monal S: What will happen? What will happen?
Monal S: It will sort the given list, store the new sorted in a new variable. That's all.
Monal S: It will never be able to give us the new value because
Monal S: We have not written any instruction.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: If we don't return anything, it means we are returning none.
Monal S: Known returning means?
Monal S: No returning means?
Monal S: None.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: So, function… Can do its job.
Monal S: But it is an optional to return something.
Monal S: It is an optional to return something.
Monal S: It can return none, Or it can return some value.
Monal S: We don't want to return. We don't want to return.
Monal S: Then… we… don't… want… updated value.
Monal S: When we want to return, In which cases we want to return?
Monal S: When we… wand.
Monal S: updated value.
Monal S: Okay? So, see this particular code now.
Monal S: Everyone, see this particular code now? Let me write DEF add dummy.
Monal S: This is a function. Here, I've written A is equals to 1, B is equals to 1.
Monal S: And I just want to print.
Monal S: Or instead of that, let me just write… Name is equals to input.
Monal S: Name equals to input.
Monal S: Enter your name. This is what we will ask user.
Monal S: And then, we will just print
Monal S: Hello.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: We will print, hello, and then the name, whatever user provided, then we will write, Comma, space.
Monal S: Greetings from Kresh Nayak Academy.
Monal S: How many of you is able to understand these two lines of code?
Monal S: How many of you is able to understand two lines of code?
Monal S: Others… Great.
Monal S: This is the function.
Monal S: Now, whenever I run this function, this function job is to take input, and then show something on the screen. Show something on the screen, not to a variable. Show something on the screen. When you're working with notebook, screen is, if you print something, we will see at the bottom.
Monal S: So, in this code, what I will do…
Monal S: I will call add dummy, it will ask me for an input, I will pass input, done.
Monal S: I'm done.
Monal S: Now tell me, does this function require… do we require something from this function?
Monal S: Do you want to save something from this function?
Monal S: This function is fine on its own.
Monal S: So, it means we don't require something from this function, that's why we are not returning anything.
Monal S: We are not returning anything.
Monal S: That is not the job.
Monal S: If you want to check what this function returns, let's see, return value, I'm creating a variable, and I will print that.
Monal S: And I will print that variable as well. So we will see this, because it's a part of the function.
Monal S: So when we run this function, take input, it will print the job, this function job is done, then we are taking the return value, let's see whether it returns or not, then we are printing the return value. Is everyone clear with the flow?
Monal S: Is everyone clear with the 4? We are calling function, it will take input, it will print. So, we will see print here. This part is done. This function will give us something, we will save it here and print. Let's see whether it prints or not.
Monal S: Let's run now.
Monal S: Again, I will write monol.
Monal S: This is printed, which is a part of function. Is it returning anything?
Monal S: Is it returning anything?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: That's why we are able to see none.
Monal S: But, in cases of other things, DF, add.
Monal S: How are we getting first line? Spandana, that's why I'm saying, do you know the flow? Then no one will say anything.
Monal S: Guys, you are not… you have to do dry run a lot, everyone.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: See this line by line? This is function definition. Last time I'm repeating. This is function definition, function definition is done.
Monal S: What is the first line?
Monal S: Add dummy.
Monal S: Okay? What Add Dummy is doing? Add dummy will take input, from the user.
Monal S: Store into name.
Monal S: store into name. What is the next thing add dummy is doing? Printing.
Monal S: Hello, Dashdash.
Monal S: Task of add them is done. That's why in terminal we are able to see hello.
Monal S: Once this task is done, we are asking, we from Python are asking.
Monal S: That, whatever you are throwing, we will store it.
Monal S: Whatever you are throwing, we will store it.
Monal S: So, ad dummies throwing what? Nothing.
Monal S: Add dummies throwing word? Nothing. Nothing means…
Monal S: None. We are storing none too.
Monal S: Return value.
Monal S: The return value is none. Then we are printing, ma'am.
Monal S: Is Pandana, are we clear?
Monal S: Anyone has doubt.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So now, let's come back to our V2. What we are doing, first of all, whenever any function will see return, it will not execute any lines of code. Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: Doubts are not addressed.
Monal S: Javind, what is your doubt?
Monal S: Javindra, what is your doubt?
Monal S: Guys, in programming languages, Nothing means… Nothing means… Nothing means… N-A, N-A-N, or none.
Monal S: Any programming languages. How will you say nothing?
Monal S: Javinder, difference between method and function.
Monal S: Javindra?
Monal S: Function is user-defined, function is standalone, method is a part of some data… method is a part of some class. Are we clear?
Monal S: I have cleared… Javinder, is this your first class?
Monal S: Jaavender, is this your first class?
Monal S: Did you attend the class where I was talking about difference between function and method? Do you remember that class?
Monal S: Not sure if I missed a certain part.
Monal S: Function is a piece of code.
Monal S: Function is a piece of code which has some name.
Monal S: Which has some name.
Monal S: Method is a piece of code that only works With a certain class type.
Monal S: If I use number of 101.split.
Monal S: It will not work, because split is… a code of string.
Monal S: So, in this case, when some lines of code is a part of a certain class, we call that as method.
Monal S: Javindra, are we clear?
Monal S: But function is not a part of anything.
Monal S: Function is just a piece of code with a name.
Monal S: Jaivendra?
Monal S: Right now, you will understand functional method later, more clearly. Until and unless we will go to the object-oriented programming, you will not understand.
Monal S: Manish, sir, I want to display custom string instead of none.
Monal S: In case… Then write if and else.
Monal S: Manish?
Monal S: Java folks has this kind of confusion. In Java, function and methods refer to same thing. Guys, in Java also, function and method is not same.
Monal S: I know Java, I have worked with Java.
Monal S: Function and method is not same.
Monal S: Never, never in any programming language.
Monal S: Toria, as with the definition function, we are not assigning any variable.
Monal S: How are we not ass- okay, it is printing none? Okay.
Monal S: Guys?
Monal S: in programming languages, something will either return… everyone understand this. Surya, you will also understand.
Monal S: In programming languages, something always returns
Monal S: Something should always return something.
Monal S: Function should always return something. Nothing is also a part of something. Value is also a part of something. Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: In programming languages, function should always return something, but the definition of something is
Monal S: It can be a nothing, it can be a value. Nothing means… Nothing means… Tell me, everyone, nothing means.
Monal S: Value means whatever we want.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: function should always return something. If we don't write return, it means we are directly going to
Monal S: If we don't write return, it means… We are directly going to… None.
Monal S: We are returning nothing. So in programming languages, nothing also has some value. That is called as none.
Monal S: I will show you.
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: I will show you, I will clear it out.
Monal S: Java does not have functions.
Monal S: Hey, everyone?
Monal S: Are we able to see these cells?
Monal S: We as humans, are calling it as empty.
Monal S: But for computer to understand empty, empty has to be something, yes or no?
Monal S: Empty has to be something. How will you tell your computer that it is empty?
Monal S: How you will tell your computer that it is empty?
Monal S: Are we able to understand this part?
Monal S: Yes, in Java, everything belongs to object class.
Monal S: So…
Monal S: In Java, everything belongs to an object class, but I'm talking in terms of object-oriented product programming, not in terms of the object class, okay?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand? These all are called as nothing cells. These are empty cells. For any programming language to understand, how will you write empty? How many of you can write empty?
Monal S: How many here are brave people who can write empty?
Monal S: Empty.
Monal S: and tell Python or any programming that is empty, you can either use none.
Monal S: Okay? When you will work and see datasets in machine learning, you will also see NA and NAN. Whenever you see these values, it means it is nothing.
Monal S: So, is this part clear to everyone? I know function takes time to understand this. Whenever people see returns, they go crazy. But is this part clear? When you don't specifically write return, it means function is going to return nothing. Nothing means none.
Monal S: When you specifically write return something, then You need to catch it.
Monal S: then you need to catch it. Yes, Surya, I read your… but this one is well answer everyone's.
Monal S: So… Now, let's create a simple Thanks.
Monal S: Subtract function, everyone.
Monal S: DEF subtract. Now I'm moving to the next part, it is 1148 already. Is everyone back for people who went to break?
Monal S: Guys, is everyone back?
Monal S: Now, let's understand, even before writing the code, even before writing the code, now let's define the problem statement. Everyone see clearly. We need to define problem statement, okay?
Monal S: we want… to create… Reusable code.
Monal S: That will… peak.
Monal S: That will take… input, from user… as a number.
Monal S: and subtract.
Monal S: and subtract. Now, if you read it, did we mention anything that we want to catch that value?
Monal S: Here, if you mention anything that we want to catch, any value, tell me.
Monal S: Archana, we don't write type here.
Monal S: Ashan, are you from Java also? Here, we did not mention anything to return, we just mentioned that we want to catch
Monal S: number, and do the subtraction from that number. That's all, okay? Now what I want to do… Once calculated.
Monal S: Return that… value. Return means… return also means… Throw that value back.
Monal S: So this function task is just to throw that value, whoever catches, not catches, is not our job.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Are we clear? So let's create that function.
Monal S: Yeah, SOL, actually, I was talking in terms of C, C++. In Java, everything has to be inside a class, yes, okay?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So… See this?
Monal S: B, E, F, subtract.
Monal S: Anyone has doubt in this part?
Monal S: Doubt in this part.
Monal S: Now, we will take… Input.
Monal S: I will just write in short, input.
Monal S: Store into variable A. Store into variable B.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Okay. Now what I will do, C equals to A minus B.
Monal S: Now, if I call this function now, if I call this function now.
Monal S: If I run this function, and user provided A is equals to 1, B is equals to 2.
Monal S: C will be 1 minus 2, 1 minus 2 is… 1 minus 2 is… Minus one.
Monal S: If I run this function, And save into… and save into value.
Monal S: What will be the answer of value? What will be the answer of value?
Monal S: Everyone, what will be the answer of value?
Monal S: In this code, did I return, did I mention anything to return?
Monal S: Answer of this will be… none.
Monal S: what one statement I am missing? Am I missing anything? This function job was to just calculate it. We did all the calculation, task done.
Monal S: Do we have any more tasks here?
Monal S: Do we have any more tasks here? No.
Monal S: Guys, it is not missing. Right now, I'm not doing anything. Now, let's see this function.
Monal S: Let me copy everything.
Monal S: And then paste it here.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Now, in this code, In this code, you guys will tell me, okay?
Monal S: It is not missing, guys.
Monal S: Missing means?
Monal S: This is a new function.
Monal S: Here, I am seeing… Once you calculate, Throw the sea as well.
Monal S: Now, what this function will do… what this function will do, it will throw the value of C. What is the value of C?
Monal S: Minus 1.
Monal S: This time, we will see minus 1 in the val, because C is throwing the value… see, now C has 2 jobs.
Monal S: do the calculation just like before, calculation done. At the end, we mention return C. Once we… once Python will see the last instruction return, it will…
Monal S: it will not execute anything further. Function task will be done, and once function task is done, function is throwing this value.
Monal S: So now, I can also write subtract. Guys, if I just write subtract and not store, is this an issue?
Monal S: Is this an issue? There is no error. Is there any error here? Is there any error? No.
Monal S: We are just not catching it. Function will keep on throwing, we are just not catching it, no one to catch.
Monal S: Is concept of return clear now to everyone?
Monal S: concept of return.
Monal S: Can we say return is equivalent of print function, but both print the values? Gitanjali.
Monal S: The return has nothing to do with print.
Monal S: Return and print are very different.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Now, see what I've written at the end. If I write… Subtract.
Monal S: plus subtract in Python.
Monal S: When I run this function, I am providing A equals to 1, A equals to 2, B equals to 2. When I'm running this code, it will ask me for input. I will write A equals to 4, B equals to 2.
Monal S: What will happen?
Monal S: Code execution will happen from top to bottom, from top to bottom, right to left, Right to left.
Monal S: What is the answer of this subtract?
Monal S: What is the answer of this subtract? Here, it is returning, I'm talking about return 1.
Monal S: It will do 4 minus 2, it will do C equals to 4 minus 2, C equals to 2, then it will return do.
Monal S: Return to. So this whole thing will be replaced by…
Monal S: This whole thing will be replaced by Luke.
Monal S: Now, we are going from right to left.
Monal S: VF… We have completed this part. What is the next operator? Plus.
Monal S: What is the next operation? Do we have the answer? No. Let's solve it.
Monal S: C equals to 2 minus 2.
Monal S: Later, Return 2. I'm just writing return 1.
Monal S: 2 minus 2 is 0, okay?
Monal S: Return 0.
Monal S: What is the answer of this block? What is the answer of this function? Zero.
Monal S: 2, we got from here, plus is here, 0 is from here. Now, again, it will solve from right to left, because this operator is still left. What is the final answer?
Monal S: Cool.
Monal S: Is this what I have written here, but for a different function?
Monal S: Quite confusing.
Monal S: Okay, yes.
Monal S: It does.
Monal S: C.
Monal S: In one of the examples I've shown you, but it will solve from left to right, okay? It will solve this, then this, then this, correct?
Monal S: Guys, it is crystal clear, we cannot do… you have to do dry run, okay?
Monal S: Top to bottom.
Monal S: Then… Left to right, okay?
Monal S: So guys, try to solve it, try to see the answer.
Monal S: We are doing it from day one.
Monal S: First, try to solve this. Whatever is the answer, it will be replaced by that. Answer plus another answer will be another operation, because plus needs to be worked.
Monal S: Alright? Done. This is about function. Guys, function will be deeper, we cannot complete function.
Monal S: Next part, is everyone ready with the next part?
Monal S: Is everyone ready with the next part?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Till now, what we are doing, we have this person.
Monal S: And we are asking this person to collect Input.
Monal S: This is what we are doing till now.
Monal S: We are asking, if this person is function, we are asking this person itself to collect the input from the user. Is this part clear?
Monal S: Is this part here what I'm saying?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So, every time when I run, it will again ask me for user input. There is another way that, to this person, we will give this person how much
Monal S: hands it wants. Each hand, we can pass input directly. Instead of asking this person to collect input, we will give input to the function itself.
Monal S: Now, see, what is the difference?
Monal S: See the difference, you will understand now.
Monal S: Dinesh, I'm doing it right now, okay? So I'm creating a new function.
Monal S: And this time, in the brackets, think of brackets as this person hands itself. How many hands we want to give? We want to give two hands. A comma, B. Hand name, whatever you want, you can give it. Okay, let me disable the chat, yes.
Monal S: Okay? Hand names, I am currently giving two hands called A and B.
Monal S: Then, in these hands, whatever user will provide, I will use these hands. If user will provide me numbers, I will do addition. If user will provide me string, I will do concatenation. If user will provide me integer and string, it will throw an error, because plus will not work. See this.
Monal S: This is add. Function definition is completed.
Monal S: In this ad, to the first hand called A, I am passing 1.
Monal S: to the second hand called B, I am passing 2.
Monal S: So, A is now 1, B is now 2, I am doing print-off, 1 plus 2.
Monal S: So… Now, this is what it looks like.
Monal S: A will go to… 1 will go to the first hand of A. It follows a sequence.
Monal S: 2 will go to the second hand, which we provided.
Monal S: Okay? To the B.
Monal S: Now, in this… inside this function itself, it will check A is having one, B is having 2. What we are doing with its own hands.
Monal S: A plus B.
Monal S: Are we returning anything?
Monal S: Are we returning anything when we are calling the function?
Monal S: None.
Monal S: Let's see.
Monal S: answer.
Monal S: Let's print the answer.
Monal S: Now, don't say why this 3 is coming, because we are printing inside the function.
Monal S: Should be answered.
Monal S: None is correct.
Monal S: Now, instead of this print, let's return the value. Now, you know, don't say, sir, how you can return A plus B. I told you, Python will solve this A plus B to the final answer. Whatever the answer is, then it will return. Now, this 1 plus 2, A will have 1, B will have 2,
Monal S: And it will return the final answer, A plus B. So this function will return A plus B, it will go to the answer, we will print the answer.
Monal S: Done. Very simple. Now see the power. Instead of asking user input, we are the one who is typing it and using this function very quickly.
Monal S: This add, if I provide both of them as string, hello.
Monal S: and void.
Monal S: What it will do? It will do concatenation.
Monal S: Because we are just using this single plus here to use.
Monal S: Now, only doubts on this, people who are not able to understand this hand concept.
Monal S: Please tell me in the chat. And people who are able to understand also say, are you able to understand this concept?
Monal S: Everyone, very simple. Hence concept I told you.
Monal S: It follows the sequence.
Monal S: People who are not able to understand, please tell me what you are not able to understand. One sequence will go to the first variable, second will go to the second variable.
Monal S: This A and B, whatever we write in between the brackets of function, A, B, C,
Monal S: We call those as… Arguments of function.
Monal S: Arguments of function.
Monal S: Where is the function return? Exactly here.
Monal S: Vidya.
Monal S: Now, see what will happen? In add, in add, if I pass 1, 2, 3. Guys, I'm passing 1, 2, 3.
Monal S: And print, because… Add will return something, print will print that returns.
Monal S: See the error?
Monal S: Add takes 2 positional arguments, but 3 were given. It is saying that add only has 2 hands, but you are giving 3 values, how it can catch it.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: If I give only one value, then it will say.
Monal S: Add requires both A and B to do the operation, but you're only giving one in one hand. What about other hand?
Monal S: It is saying it is missing one positional argument B. You have not passed anything in B. So whenever you pass one, it will only go to the first argument, A.
Monal S: Guys, I'm in the next topic itself. This is next topic.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: Guys, I'm teaching you, don't worry, wait, okay? So, here we are able to see that when we… when user will pass only one value, it is giving us error.
Monal S: It is giving us error. Please show what code ones.
Monal S: I will paste the code.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Now, let's think of an… another scenario.
Monal S: Next scenario.
Monal S: This is person… Person has two hands, this hand is called A, this hand is called B.
Monal S: Okay? Here, when we pass two value, When we pass two values.
Monal S: this person is happy. This person will say, okay, you provided me two values, whatever operation you do with those two values is totally different. First person needs to have those two values. This A and B is called as… A and B is called as arguments.
Monal S: Arguments of a function.
Monal S: Okay? Now, what this person is saying that…
Monal S: This person wants some kind of a surety.
Monal S: If user will not provide me any value, I still want to do something.
Monal S: I don't want to depend on user to provide me those two values.
Monal S: And, if user will not provide me, I want to do some basic job.
Monal S: I want to do some basic operations still if user will not provide me. So here, what user is asking? Here, what this person is asking, tell me.
Monal S: This person is asking help that if someone is not providing me the correct value, or the value itself, in the case of when we mentioned subtract of 1.
Monal S: We only provided 1 to the A, but B got nothing.
Monal S: Now this person is unhappy.
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this? Now this person is unhappy.
Monal S: So let's solve this person's issue.
Monal S: We will tell this person that at the start, at the start, in your both hands, we will give some default value, which will not change the operation.
Monal S: Person A, name is A, this one is B.
Monal S: Can I give it 0 at the start? Will 0 change anything in the operation?
Monal S: Will 0 change anything in the operation?
Monal S: Now, if user will provide me the value, this person is saying, when user will provide me the value, I will throw this value and will take the new value which user provided.
Monal S: If user will provide me the value, I will throw whatever I had before, I will take the new value.
Monal S: Okay? I will take the new value. If user will not provide me any value, I will… whatever I have, I will deal with that.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: These are called as… default… arguments.
Monal S: Let's see how to create default arguments. So, default arguments is used to create more robust function. Previously, the function was A comma B.
Monal S: We were doing something with A, or B, that is, we are doing addition.
Monal S: But right now, if I provide… if I just call add, suppose user forgot what to pass.
Monal S: It is giving us error. If user know, I can pass 10. Still an error. User needs to pass everything in order to make it work. It is working.
Monal S: This is a little bit an issue. We want user to have better experience. So, in the first hand, we will provide by default value. In the second hand, we will provide by default value. It is totally up to you what you want to provide.
Monal S: So, if I don't pass anything, tell me, does this function have values in its hands?
Monal S: Does this function have values in its hands? Yes.
Monal S: So, if I run it… guys…
Monal S: It has values in its hands.
Monal S: When I'm calling this function without any value, what function will say? Okay, you did not provide me anything, I will still do my job with what I have.
Monal S: Next!
Monal S: User is passing 100, but user don't want to pass the next value. What will happen?
Monal S: User will throw… this function will throw the old value 0, will catch the new 100.
Monal S: But D still have 0 because we are not asking this function to throw the old value.
Monal S: 100 plus 0 is?
Monal S: Ended plus zero is… Handred.
Monal S: It will still work.
Monal S: like the old one, that is 200. So just by giving its default value, we are able to deal with other cases as well.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Are we clear? Very simple.
Monal S: Very simple.
Monal S: So, it is truly possible
Monal S: you can have your function like this as well. But see, it is saying that whenever you are creating a default value.
Monal S: See this, everyone? Python, what Python is saying? Non-default arguments follow default argument. See this?
Monal S: Non-default argument. Which one is non-default? A or B? Which one is non-default? B is non-default. So, if you hover over it, what it is saying, non-default should follow default argument. It means…
Monal S: It is saying that the first argument, if it has nothing, B should have C.
Monal S: Let me tell you.
Monal S: Because Python follows a sequence, Guys, you can try whatever you want. Hemant, you can try that, yes?
Monal S: what Python is saying, that…
Monal S: You cannot put B, which is a non-default argument, at the second place when you already have… when you already have default argument in the first place. That is not accepted.
Monal S: You can keep non-default first.
Monal S: and default second, this is accepted. But non-default in the second and default in the first is not accepted.
Monal S: So, first priority will go to non-default, then we will pass default.
Monal S: Is… are we clear what exactly it means?
Monal S: Are we clear what exactly it means?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: Is everyone enjoying the class? I know class is a little bit complex, complexity is increasing because you are going to the function.
Monal S: Because we are going to the function. But still, it is fun, because whatever we have learned, now we are just using it. Whatever we have learned, we are using it.
Monal S: Okay? Now, let me give you a very good example.
Monal S: Everyone, I'm giving you very good example. See this. This assignment I might be able to give you, it is already 12-13, so let's start, okay? Other parts of the class will be very simple once you guys will revise it. I will not teach you more. Is that fine?
Monal S: Or do you want to learn more?
Monal S: What do you mean by clear behind the scene?
Monal S: See, guys, it is pretty natural.
Monal S: If you create… if you create things like this.
Monal S: And while calling the function 1, 1 will always go to…
Monal S: One will always go to A.
Monal S: But A already has… A already has default value.
Monal S: Which is better?
Monal S: If I pass add of 1, now 1 will go to A, B already has default value.
Monal S: Which one is better for coding point of view? Which one is more standard?
Monal S: This one will make sure that you have less error. This one has more errors.
Monal S: Repeat function part.
Monal S: Guys, function, which part do you want me to repeat?
Monal S: See how many lines of code we have in function. Tell me which part you want me to repeat.
Monal S: Where is the function?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Guys, tell me which function R, which function you want me to repeat.
Monal S: I will repeat it, but tell me what exactly where you are having issue.
Monal S: Start one at the very start, or are you able to understand the basic of function, or you skip the whole function?
Monal S: Why return is used? Okay. I will teach you separately, okay? At the end of the class, I will teach you.
Monal S: Okay? Or… is anyone who does not understand the return, please tell me?
Monal S: Anyone who does not re… who does not understand return, tell me, I will teach at the end.
Monal S: In the doubt session.
Monal S: Vijay, I'm seeing your comments.
Monal S: Guys, I… I'm not sure, I know you guys also hate when I don't see your comments, but the first thing is…
Monal S: It's not like I don't see your comments.
Monal S: Okay? Everyone's comment is here, but I'm not able to show you how many chats we have. It keeps on scrolling fast.
Monal S: Anyone?
Monal S: If we are using default value, then we can't create print function with signature like print. We can use it
Monal S: The rain print is used for…
Monal S: The rain print is used for?
Monal S: Everyone, I want you to understand one thing very clearly.
Monal S: Print and function.
Monal S: Print and return are two very different things.
Monal S: But first, let me give you guys one function which you guys can revise and do, dry run and understand. Then only I will write complex things. How many of you, if I write a function, a complex function, you guys will try to debug it and understand it, just understand it? How many of you will do that?
Monal S: People who will not be able to do it, leave it to the next class, but…
Monal S: Again, I'm giving assignment.
Monal S: It is.
Monal S: Don't say explain, it is a part of assignment. I will explain next class.
Monal S: Just wait, okay?
Monal S: In the meantime, you guys can do the feedback, so let me also share that.
Monal S: That's true feedback, okay?
Monal S: Not the annoyed one.
Monal S: I'm already trying my best, okay?
Monal S: Enter…
Monal S: Program is almost done.
Monal S: So… Just wait for one more minute.
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys.
Monal S: Guys, I will not teach anything more, just after this assignment, I'm not going to give you a PDF assignment, because I think a lot of you are not ready.
Monal S: So I will give you next week. But all the assignments which I've given here, dry run, that is your assignment, okay?
Monal S: Don't be scared, it is really simple, but just bunch of things in a single place.
Monal S: Is everyone clear with the assignment?
Monal S: Understand each and everything here. It is very, very, very simple. Understand what I'm doing here, then check, when I run this, why it works in a certain way, what we will be able to do with it.
Monal S: Alright? This is today's assignment. Do dry run, whatever feels good to you, but there are a lot of assignments that you need to understand. There are a lot of things like return. I want everyone to focus here.
Monal S: Because after function, function still has more things. Once the function is done, we have completed the basics.
Monal S: We will go to the intermediate part. So this is the last part of the basic Python function.
Monal S: Okay? Function has more things, but…
Monal S: at least by this, we are able to understand function and function arguments. Argument topic, I will teach you more, but…
Monal S: It is still left.
Monal S: Okay? For now, it is more than enough.
Monal S: Everyone happy?
Monal S: Is everyone happy? Guys… So, let me save everything. Very happy.
Monal S: Please revise. Revision is something which I want all of you to do it
Monal S: A lot. The more you see Python, The more you will understand.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, for people, guys, I will also attach this assignment in the zip. Not everything I have taught in the class. Whoever wants to do it still, you guys can check it.
Monal S: Assignment is… From my side, this assignment, you guys are not ready.
Monal S: So I will still attach it. People who want to make it, learn it, they can do it. Otherwise, leave it, ignore this assignment at all. The only assignment is present in Class Notes PDF.
Monal S: As well as this notebook file which we created. Okay?
Monal S: Sir, you were explaining something, could you please explain? Yes, guys, this is the assignment, that's all. There is nothing. This is the assignment. What happened?
Monal S: You guys need to run it, understand it, that's the only thing. That's all. This is what I was explaining.
Monal S: whoever is done with the class, please leave today's class, enjoy your weekend, and guys, we don't have Wednesday class, I already mentioned that, so we will meet on Saturday. Alright? Saturday.
Monal S: Anything you guys want to learn about syllabus, what is going to be covered, what not, please check the syllabus.
Monal S: If you have a habit of checking the syllabus, what is covered, what is not, it will help you. Otherwise, we will have 100 questions every day on syllabus, okay?
Monal S: Alright.
Monal S: So, let me stop sharing, zip it for people, and then start the doubt session.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: I'm also adding the assignment, as you guys told me.
Monal S: That assignment, which is not supposed to be this week, but I'm also adding it.
Monal S: Give me a second. I'm uploading the assignments.
Monal S: In our community as well.
Monal S: And I totally understand. If something is, not understandable, if something is confusing, it's confusing, okay? I'm not saying function is something that is
Monal S: Very easy to understand at the first day.
Monal S: But soon, everyone will be able to create function on the go.
Monal S: You will not even think about it.
Monal S: Where is that final thing?
Monal S: is here.
Monal S: I have also updated on the Notion, where we have everything.
Monal S: No, not yet, but I'm updating it, okay?
Monal S: 25012026.
Monal S: No.
Monal S: So what we have done in this class, let me also write it, so we can close that part, and then start the doubt.
Monal S: So, in today's class, we have
Monal S: Revised our string methods… not revised.
Monal S: string methods… loop. Again, we see… We saw loops.
Monal S: functions… And… function arguments.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: Ben?
Monal S: Everyone will be able to see the same.
Monal S: in the Notion, as well as in the community, I've also pasted. I'm not saying is assignment provided, because that assignment I will again share. It is not supposed to be today's class.
Monal S: So… Done.
Monal S: Okay, let's start the road session.
Monal S: Where is Zoom?
Monal S: This assignment code is running. What is the assignment then? No, this assign… guys, Anurag assignment is…
Monal S: Just to dry run, understand, revise a lot of things, okay?
Monal S: I have prepared assignment, but I feel like you guys require more…
Monal S: natural understanding how to run it, how to do that. I've also attached the zip here. Guys, I've shared the zip also here, you can see.
Monal S: Alright, let me end the poll.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Only people who has doubt, please raise hand. Other people, we can discuss things later, okay?
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys, for joining.
Monal S: Thank you, enjoy the weekend, see you, bye-bye.
Monal S: Bye, guys, bye.
Monal S: All right, Anuj?
Monal S: Guys, there are 16 hands raised, so…
Monal S: 17 months.
Monal S: Anoj?
Monal S: Anna just dropped.
Monal S: Can't.
Monal S: Thank you very much, guys. Thank you, happy weekend.
Monal S: Sir, how can I talk to you? Ravi, you just are… you just need to raise your hand, you're the third person, okay?
Monal S: Are you there?
kanth: Most of them, I haven't work.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Anth, what is the query?
kanth: But…
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: Rummit, I will explain, okay?
Monal S: Calculator works, that's great.
Monal S: Gone?
Monal S: Do you have a glitty?
Monal S: If you have an issue, maybe I can take someone else's query.
kanth: No, sir, I don't have anything.
Monal S: Alright, thank you very much.
Monal S: Right, then we have Ishug oil.
Monal S: You should go in.
Ishu Goyal: Hey, hi Monal, Kanika this side.
Ishu Goyal: Oh, thank you.
Monal S: How you gonna go? Yes.
Ishu Goyal: I have one question, from today's class, actually. So, when you were teaching about the string methods, we study about the one method that is find, which is used to find the index of any string character, okay? And it output… it outputs minus 1 if that character is not found, correct?
Ishu Goyal: So, I was having a question, like, whatever strings that you provided, actually, it was containing, usually one character. So, let's say, if I have a string, for example, MOMMOM,
Ishu Goyal: So, there are two characters, that are similar. Like, we have a long string in which we have the multiple characters, so how can…
Monal S: Provided the first instance.
Ishu Goyal: instance.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes. It will only provide if two mom are present in a big, big string, right?
Monal S: And if you want to find MOM, whatever MOM is first from the 0th index, right, it will go from left to right. Whatever is first, it will provide you that index.
Ishu Goyal: So, it's not possible for us, like, for example, in a full sentence, 3 moms are present, so it's…
Monal S: second one.
Monal S: Yeah.
Monal S: I mean, if I need to find wherever the second mom is present.
Ishu Goyal: So, how can I find that index in that string?
Monal S: Private it.
Monal S: Okay, where is it?
Monal S: Just tweak.
Ishu Goyal: just got this question, because in the first assignment, when I was validating my answers with ChatGPT at that time, I learned to find the enumerate.
Ishu Goyal: But, to find the index and value both in strings, so…
Monal S: You can, you can do that as well. See, there is something, called as… just let me give you…
Monal S: Because… To…
Monal S: I personally use Regex for it, okay? But Regex, I've not told you yet, so I'm not working on the Regx.
Ishu Goyal: Okay.
Monal S: Thing.
Monal S: to find…
Monal S: See, using find, what we have to do, we kind of have to create a logic, okay?
Ishu Goyal: Okay.
Monal S: Direct method is not available using Find. You have to use regex.
Monal S: I can tell you how to do it, but… okay, I will explain. See this.
Monal S: Hmm… are you able to see the screen?
Ishu Goyal: Yes?
Monal S: For this, let's suppose the statement is like… MOM… A, B, C… M-O-M, ABC, M-O-M. Yes?
Ishu Goyal: Yes.
Monal S: Yes? So, what you will do, there is something in the find which will also help you extract, something like starts with. There is another method for it, okay? Okay. So, let me give you that how many words are present there.
Monal S: I'm just looking at… the exact word, if I will be able to find… yes, yes, yes, find it.
Monal S: So, we will start searching from here. First, we will use…
Monal S: Find… this string name is A.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So we will do a.findOfMob.
Monal S: Okay? What is the first index here, currently?
Ishu Goyal: C, zero?
Monal S: 0 is the first index. Then what people do, we currently have not learned slicing.
Monal S: So what we will do, we will do 0 plus 1 colon. This is what we do slicing. So we will create a new string starting from here.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Ishu Goyal: Okay.
Monal S: we will note down this index 0. What we will do, in this new string, now we will find more. Is this going to be triggered? No.
Ishu Goyal: No.
Monal S: What is going to be triggered? This one.
Ishu Goyal: This one, right?
Monal S: We already have one index, yes, at which index we were able to find. So we have removed that. So what we will do, we will use that again to append and look
Monal S: find this one. This one was able to find in the 0th index. Let's suppose this one is find in the 10th, alright? So we will then extract that this is 10th, we already have 1 index, so this will become the 9th index.
Monal S: You already removed one, right?
Ishu Goyal: Yes, yes, okay.
Monal S: this will become 9. Once we found this 9, then what we will do? We will do the…
Monal S: 9. Previously, we removed what?
Monal S: Zero.
Ishu Goyal: Zero.
Monal S: 9 colon, we need to write a logic like this, okay? So from 9 all the way, we will again cut this new string.
Monal S: Now, in this final string, where is mom? In this particular place. We will get this index, so based on this, we need to create a logic like this. But this is, again, a very,
Monal S: iterative method, which is not good, but if you find regex.
Monal S: Okay? Regex will be able to find all the instances at once, using Find All.
Ishu Goyal: Okay. Okay.
Monal S: So later we will learn, but this is, again, like, computative programming thing which you need to learn, okay?
Ishu Goyal: Okay, okay, no issues. We'll land it later.
Ishu Goyal: Yeah, sure.
Monal S: Alright? But at least you have an idea, right? That port, we will be doing it.
Ishu Goyal: Yes, I'll try to build the same at my end.
Monal S: Sure, sure, sure, yes?
Ishu Goyal: Yeah.
Monal S: Yeah.
Ishu Goyal: Okay, thank you.
Monal S: Yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: And next is our panel, you are here.
Monal S: Tell me, what is the issue.
R: Good afternoon, sir, sir, my name is Anshuman.
Monal S: An Schumann.
R: Yeah, sir. Yes, sir. Sir, actually, the thing is, I am having doubt after the return part, like, why are we using it?
R: And what is the use case of it? Like, I did not understand it.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, let me first check. How many of you have the same issue? Please raise… please answer in the chat.
Monal S: That's great, Gaurav. Awesome.
Monal S: Others, AMR, Monmouth, others?
Monal S: I do, that's great.
Monal S: No, sir, not same point. Can you please explain string formatting? Guys, slicing and other things which we have not learned. Later, we will do slicing.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Just wait, okay?
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Alright, having doubts from yesterday, Vijay, we'll figure it out.
Monal S: Now let's understand this with a normal layman understanding. You have a problem statement, okay?
Monal S: You want to… by apples.
Monal S: Okay? You want to buy apples?
Monal S: online.
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: They want to buy apples.
Monal S: Only.
Monal S: Okay? So what you will do, you will use the app to place an order for Apple. Yes?
Monal S: Is this part clear? Yes, sir.
Monal S: Okay?
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: And what you want, at the end, You want your apple back.
Monal S: Once you place the order. Yes?
Monal S: So, there are two scenarios. Yes, sir. Scenario one. Once you place an order, then, once you place an order for the apple.
Monal S: A delivery person got assigned to you.
Monal S: A delivery person got assigned to you, and ate the apple, or took the apple to himself.
Monal S: the person assigned it to your, product, or to your order ID, and…
Monal S: He has the apple to himself.
Monal S: Is the task completed?
R: No sir.
Monal S: What is left?
R: No so.
R: So the delivery of… the delivery of the apples is still left, so…
Monal S: Yes, this is you as a person.
Monal S: You have placed, apple is done, delivery person has it, but is the apple
Monal S: Available to you? No. It is not available.
R: But also…
Monal S: This is a case where this delivery person is not returning something.
Monal S: It is doing the job.
Monal S: App is doing the job, delivery person did half of the job, but the job says that you're buying the apple, it means you want to have the apple.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: This particular problem statement will be okay if you are asking questions like, you want…
Monal S: You want to… Buy Apple.
Monal S: online.
Monal S: And… Want delivery person to keep it.
Monal S: And want delivery?
Monal S: Person to keep it.
Monal S: If this is the problem statement, then is the current scenario fine?
R: Neutral.
Monal S: want to buy Apple. No, it is correct, right? You want to buy Apple online and want delivery person to keep it. Now, is this whole thing which we have done, is this correct or not?
R: Yeah, this one's fine.
Monal S: This is fine.
Monal S: So, our ask was, we don't want Apple. We want to buy, and one delivery person to keep it. So here, what we are requesting, are we requesting anything?
Monal S: Ottawa.
R: No, sir.
Monal S: Anything? No.
Monal S: So when we don't want to request anything, we don't write return. It's this part here?
R: Okay, yes, sir.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
R: You know.
Monal S: So, when you want Apple, then only you will write return.
Monal S: Is this part here now?
R: Thank you. PSO.
R: This is add function.
Monal S: You, you understood the concept of 2,3 variable, yes?
R: Yes, I am.
Monal S: So this particular add function, A comma B, And it does one job.
Monal S: It does print. Is this part clear now? This is function.
R: You too.
Monal S: While you are placing the order, you said, in A I want to pass 2, in A I want to pass 1, B I want to pass 2.
Monal S: Alright?
R: Yeah, so…
Monal S: Do you want something from this function?
Monal S: Currently, are we… are we asking anything from the function?
Monal S: We are, in this function instruction, we have written that, just print it. It is a task of the function to print it.
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Okay? And right now, is function doing its job in the terminal? Print job is to print 3.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Now, in another case, what you want, you want to do 1 plus Add of 3, comma 4.
R: Beautiful.
Monal S: 1, you want to do whatever is the addition of 4, 3, you want that to be added with 1.
Monal S: In the current scenario, you have add of 3, 4. What will be the answer of this?
Monal S: What is the answer of this in the current function?
Monal S: dedicated function.
Monal S: In the current function, 1 plus, is this function returning anything?
R: No, sir.
Monal S: Is this function printing something in the console?
R: It's…
Monal S: will print 7. This function will print 7 because it is its task.
Monal S: But this function is not giving something. So if this is not giving something means…
R: Okay…
Monal S: Function is doing its job. Function is doing its job, but we are using this function with something else which is not something which we want.
Monal S: We are asking this function to keep the apple to itself, but we are also asking to give me back. Is this possible?
R: Not so.
Monal S: We ask delivery person to bring the apple back, then only it will bring the apple back. But if we are asking that delivery person, which is the function, to keep the apple to himself.
Monal S: function keeping its task to himself, whatever task it is doing. Print job is just to print, right? If I remove print, now it will be simple for you to understand, because I think people are getting confused with print. Now, if I do C equals to A plus B,
Monal S: What will happen?
Monal S: Now let's remove everything.
Monal S: Okay? Now if I do 1 plus add of 3 comma 4, This function job is to…
Monal S: Add 3 plus 4 store into C.
Monal S: This function job is done.
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Is this, now you're doing 1 plus… now Python will say, you have written this function, and you want to do some operation with the output. Does this function return anything?
R: No sir.
Monal S: No means.
R: None.
Monal S: Is this operation possible?
R: No sir.
Monal S: Now, let's create a version 2.
R: So, sir, in this case, it will show error, or just one…
Monal S: This function will execute its job. The output of this function, when added with 1 will create error.
Monal S: Error will happen at this stage, not at this stage, because function is doing its job. C equals to 3 plus 4.
R: Okay…
Monal S: Now I'm creating addV2.
Monal S: A comma, B.
Monal S: C equals to A plus B.
Monal S: The return C. We are asking delivery person to get the apples and give the apple back to us.
Monal S: get the apples, give the apples back to us. Now, if I do 1 plus add of V2.
Monal S: 3 comma 7. Let's see how Python is going to take it. Python is saying that you want to add 1 plus something.
Monal S: What is something?
Monal S: Something is this.
Monal S: returned value.
R: Is this something, return something, yes or no? Yes, sir.
Monal S: If it is yes, it means it is not none.
Monal S: Right?
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: What is this yes? Let's solve this.
Monal S: Mark?
Monal S: In A, we will pass 3. B, we will pass 7. This will be…
R: In…
Monal S: 3 plus 7.
Monal S: C is holding a value of… C is holding a value of… 10. Yes?
R: I guess so.
Monal S: After C is calculated, what we are doing? We are throwing this value, yes?
Monal S: We are growing this value. So, this something will be replaced with… Whatever it is throwing.
R: Okay…
Monal S: It is throwing what? It is throwing what? C. What is C? 10.
Monal S: Now, is it solvable?
Monal S: Is it solvable?
R: ESO.
Monal S: Are we clear?
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Alright?
R: So, return is something which we don't always mention, it totally depends on.
Monal S: Whether we want to keep the apple, or we don't want to keep the apple.
R: Okay, so…
Monal S: Okay? Think of this as, like, if you want to open WhatsApp application.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: If you want to open WhatsApp application, WhatsApp application gives you screen yes or no.
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: If you open WhatsApp application, And your WhatsApp will not show anything.
Monal S: What it means? It is not returning you the screen, but is WhatsApp running? Yes.
R: Yes, sir.
Monal S: like your operating system. There are a lot of things running, but are you able to see?
R: No, sir.
Monal S: Because in its task, we didn't mention to returners. We asked them to do their job.
R: Okay, so in the backend, they are running, but since we didn't ask for the return, we can.
Monal S: Yes, yes, see this, I have a lot of… Things running.
Monal S: Yes, you can see I have a lot of things running, but are we able to see that? Not everything.
R: No, sir.
Monal S: what we are able to see, when I open Taskbar, when I open, see, when I click this button of Task Manager.
Monal S: I am asking to run the function of task manager and return me the visuals. I am able to see visuals.
R: Are we clear? Yes, sir.
Monal S: So, it is totally upon us as a developer, whether we want to return something or not. Not always we return, but we only return when we require it.
R: pizza.
Monal S: Alright? Is everyone clear who was not able to understand this part before? Others in the chat?
Monal S: Others in the chat, are we able to understand what we are not able to understand before?
Monal S: Guys, this is the simplest example of what we can do.
Monal S: Yes? Alright. I hope you understood now. That's great.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: All right, thank you very much, and then we have…
Monal S: On this album, you're… you're next. Can we use add, add one? Yes, you can use it!
Monal S: Shivangi, that is great that you're doing it. You can use it.
Pandiselvam: Hello, hi, Manal, sir.
Monal S: Hello, yes.
Pandiselvam: Yeah, Monica. So, when we are using the coding pod, right, there are, like, a string value, and you are using some prompt, right? So, how do we know that which prompt we can use for which function?
Monal S: That part, we need to remember.
Pandiselvam: Sorry?
Monal S: That part, we need to remember as developers, okay?
Pandiselvam: Okay, okay.
Monal S: One who is… in Java, someone who's working in Java, C, C++.
Monal S: They might remember some function, but when you jump to another programming language, there the function might be different. That's where chaos happens. But there is no work… there is no other way.
Pandiselvam: which programming language you're working, we should understand that.
Monal S: A split will work with string, integer will have some other things, list will have something, so that is something which we need to remember, okay?
Pandiselvam: Okay, so do we have any list in that, sir? We just go through it so that we could understand, right?
Monal S: See, that part, you need to write kind of notes, okay? See, in previous class, if I show you.
Monal S: In previous class, where is our previous class? Here.
Monal S: It was yesterday.
Pandiselvam: Right? This is notes.
Monal S: Here, if you see, while recap, are you able to see this?
Pandiselvam: Yeah, this part, I know that, yeah.
Monal S: Think of it like, think of it like, write your own notes. Okay. See, at the start, you are like this, but when you are working in a development project of Python and something, what you will do, you don't have to even remember all of this or write notes. We have Google.
Monal S: If you want to do something, Google it, then use it. But if you know something that it is not even existing, will you be able to search in Google?
Pandiselvam: Nope.
Monal S: So, to search in Google, we need to know that there are things I will label. So this is just about understanding that, that's all, okay?
Pandiselvam: Okay, sir, okay, thank you.
Monal S: Yes, you're welcome.
Monal S: Anchor return should be small, R-A-T-U-R-N. It is a keyword. All the keywords in Python are case-sensitive. Whatever Python mentioned, we need to follow that case.
Monal S: String formatting, guys, we did some string, but there are a lot of things, like slicing and others, which we will learn later. It is better to learn them during Pandas and NumPy as well, okay? Better.
Monal S: But we will see. Vamishi, we will see, okay? Gitanjli, you're next.
Monal S: People who are… those doubts are already cleared before, please unraise your hand.
Geetanjli Mathur: Hi, Mona. Good afternoon. So, your explanation of, you know, the, return was, was lovely, actually, and it cleared all my doubts regarding return. However, when I compare it to print, print, I know it cannot be used along with the def, function.
Geetanjli Mathur: This is what I'm understanding.
Monal S: using def, no, printing… see.
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay.
Monal S: Understand that print job is just to print something.
Monal S: Okay. Okay? Think of that as, like, you actually have a printer in your system, alright? And whenever you click print, it does the print job, that's all. Print job is to print that paper. Our paper is either that black screen, or that window below where we run the code.
Monal S: That is print-only has control over that, that's all.
Geetanjli Mathur: And the instruction has to be already given to it as to whether it has to do an addition or subtraction or something like that, so it will not pick up the value of the.
Monal S: Print does not solve it, okay? I will show you. Sometimes it happens if I provide print 2, 3.
Monal S: print 2, 3. Print 2 plus 3, yes?
Monal S: It is not print who is doing the addition.
Monal S: It is Python, when C is operator, Python starts solving 2 plus 3 is equals to 5. This whole thing will be replaced with
Monal S: 5. Now it is the job of print to print 5 in your screen.
Monal S: So this part is Python's job, then Python will check this instruction, then solve it. Print is not doing the addition, this plus is doing the addition.
Geetanjli Mathur: Understood. Yes, yes. So, basically, when we are using it along with depth, it still becomes a part of depth, right? Yes.
Monal S: Wherever you write print, print if you write without def, print if you write in def, the only task of print is whatever we provide in between.
Monal S: Just print it.
Monal S: Okay. It has no constraint with dev or any… anywhere else, okay?
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay, understood. And Monal, you were also explaining, I have certain doubt, regarding one aspect.
Monal S: You said that the non-default value will come first, and the default value will come later. Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: So, if you don't mind, can you please, like.
Monal S: Yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: Show me one example.
Monal S: This is, again, ADD, okay? Add has A, B. This is normal. These are… does not have any default value.
Monal S: In Python, Python states a rule that you cannot create something like this.
Monal S: That is, default first and non-default second.
Monal S: Okay? Python tells that, because in add, if I pass 1, 2, 1 will go to A, which already has a default value. Yes?
Monal S: B?
Monal S: Okay, if I pass like this, add a 1.
Monal S: How many values I'm passing?
Geetanjli Mathur: Manually.
Monal S: How many values are present here?
Geetanjli Mathur: One.
Monal S: Two. Two arguments. Two arguments.
Monal S: Yes?
Geetanjli Mathur: Seems to arguments.
Monal S: One will go to A, which already had some value.
Monal S: does a B is, again, error, because we are not passing error. So, in this particular case, we are getting what? Error.
Monal S: But… If I follow the rule of Python and make something like this.
Monal S: And when I pass add of 1, will it create any error?
Geetanjli Mathur: No, it won't.
Monal S: So, it is just to make our system error-prone.
Monal S: Okay. Okay, so Python has defined some rules which we need to follow, and this rule makes sense, yes?
Geetanjli Mathur: Hmm.
Monal S: How can we pass directly value to a B? It is not possible, we need to pass one by one.
Monal S: It's just to make this time error report, alright?
Geetanjli Mathur: So can we also say that it is positional value kind of a thing?
Monal S: it is always positional, it always follows sequence. If you pass A, B, 1, 2, it always go in sequence.
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay, okay.
Monal S: In next class, we will learn some keyword arguments, which is not positional, but we will learn it later, okay?
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay, thank you so much, Marlon.
Monal S: You're welcome, you're welcome.
Monal S: Alright,
Monal S: Ananta, I am not able to see that option to enable copy code. I tried looking at the main settings of Zoom, but let me check…
Monal S: Let me check, okay?
Monal S: Does it have an option?
Monal S: Guys, I cannot see that option.
Monal S: Aranda?
Monal S: I'm not able to see that option.
Monal S: Really sorry for that. I do want to enable it, but not able to see that option in the admin page as well.
Monal S: I will check from the webpage as well, okay?
Monal S: Yes, great, guys. If your divorce value gets cleared, that's great, alright?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Pradilute? Pradette, you're next.
Monal S: What, dude?
Pradyut Saha: Yeah, hi.
Pradyut Saha: Actually, I posted the message as well there. I'm asking, if there is any… am I notable?
Monal S: Yes, we already worked with you, yes.
Pradyut Saha: So…
Pradyut Saha: I'm asking about that, one message is, if we can check in our, means, long, long string, if we can check, there is a, first, means, uppercase in our first.
Monal S: Something happened with Prodiot?
Monal S: But, Vignis, you're next.
Monal S: You, Ganesh?
Vignesh S: Hello?
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Vignesh S: So, first of all, thank you, sir. The explanations and everything was very neat and clean, and we are able to understand it. However, so with this example, the TAPL example which you showcased just now, right?
Monal S: Which one?
Vignesh S: The apple, that has been delivered.
Monal S: Oh, okay.
Vignesh S: With respect to that, I understand the… so, I understand the core difference between the print and the written, that part.
Monal S: But…
Vignesh S: On the first scenario, right, well, the delivery person kept the apple to himself.
Vignesh S: So, in such case… so, I just wanted to relate with respect to the real-time example. Say, for example, ideally, we'll be returning the value from the function and keep, use it in any other variables for our calculation. So, that is where we majorly go for a function.
Monal S: Miss, miss, yes.
Vignesh S: Right? So, how do we handle the other scenario, or what would be the use case of the other?
Monal S: There are… yes.
Vignesh S: executing the function.
Monal S: Hmm.
Vignesh S: But it's not returning anything, or… I don't get the use case of that.
Monal S: Understand, see.
Monal S: I will talk about it. So, say this.
Monal S: This one you will understand more when we go to object-oriented programming, okay? But let's suppose I want to do something like this. Just wait. Yes.
Monal S: You will understand more in object-oriented programming, where you want to use some kind of… in object-oriented programming, functions are called as methods in Python.
Monal S: Okay? You will understand why.
Monal S: So, what you will do… I'm just giving you a flow, because right now it is out of the concept, okay? Out of the scope, out of the scope. So, here, what we want to do…
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: I am creating a function, let's suppose I want to create Microsoft Paint.
Monal S: Okay? I want to create Microsoft Paint. My first function is to Open Canvas.
Monal S: Okay?
Vignesh S: Open Canvas. So, when I open Canvas, I will see the screen.
Monal S: Yes?
Vignesh S: Yeah.
Monal S: I will see the screen. Then what I will do, there will be some functions which I want to be ready, because this is visualization.
Monal S: This is only visualization, yes? Now, what I want before Open Canvas, I will be writing something like, Get?
Monal S: Screen… oh, yes.
Monal S: Set. Screen Details.
Monal S: This is my function. This function task is to set some variables.
Monal S: What it means, when you start with this one, you will see the boxes, yes or no?
Monal S: In Microsoft Paint?
Monal S: It should have a coordinate, coordinate starting from 00, yes?
Vignesh S: Okay.
Monal S: It could have been started from in the center, yes or no?
Vignesh S: Whenever we homeland, it starts.
Monal S: Okay, no, no, no. If I talk about Microsoft Paint, you will see some of the options tools here, yes?
Vignesh S: Okay.
Monal S: present here, yes? So this tool's present location is starting from… Starting from top left.
Monal S: Did we write any of this top left? No.
Monal S: Who set it? This kind of function, task is to just set these values, so we can do other job. Is this function returning us something? No.
Monal S: It is setting some of the variable in a bigger program.
Monal S: So, there will be a lot of functions which does not return, but does some job which will be used by other functions.
Monal S: Right now, we are not in object-oriented programming, we don't know the shared memory concept. But when we work with classes and others, we will have shared memory, some function will do job, just to make things… just to set some things.
Monal S: Okay.
Vignesh S: okay, okay, sir, yeah.
Monal S: Okay? Similarly, when I open… when we open our operating system.
Monal S: And when we click on .mp3 file, okay?
Monal S: mp3 file will only be… will only be, you can say, running when the MP3 player is already running, yes?
Monal S: If MP3 player is not running, or not present, will you be able to open MP3?
Vignesh S: No.
Monal S: No. So this one, does it return something? No. When you start operating system, this function already starts running. When you open MP3, it will go to the MP3 player, MP3 player will open the visualization, and you will see the screen. This is return. But are we returning anything here?
Monal S: No.
Vignesh S: No.
Monal S: Are you clear? Okay. So there will be a lot of jobs, yes, there will be a lot of things, okay?
Vignesh S: Okay, okay, sir. And one other thing, sir.
Monal S: Yes, sure.
Vignesh S: So, in our string methods, right,
Vignesh S: Particularly with respect to split. So, initially, you defined the value in string, that str value underscore 3 equal to, you mentioned some string value, enclosed within double.
Monal S: string, empty string, right? Yes.
Vignesh S: No, no, you mentioned some default value for the… for explaining the split operation.
Monal S: Do you remember the variable name?
Vignesh S: STR underscore value underscore 3.
Monal S: Yes.
Vignesh S: Yeah, so here we have defined the variable with this monol date of birth, phone number, and this is a string value. But when we do the split, and I also noticed in other functions as well, it returns a list by default, so…
Monal S: S…
Vignesh S: Kind of a…
Monal S: That is how it is made. That is how it is made. See, currently, when I talk about this return which we are doing, okay, where is this return?
Monal S: Here is the return. Yeah, return A plus B. So if I provide 1 plus 2, 1 is an integer, 2 is also integer, integer plus integer will give you integer.
Vignesh S: integers. So, are we returning what kind of data type?
Vignesh S: No. So, by default, based on the data types, or the type of data which we handle.
Monal S: That is by default. If we want to do our own, we can define what we want.
Monal S: Okay. Find something like DEF, add, just creating a dummy, okay?
Vignesh S: -
Monal S: Return list?
Vignesh S: Okay.
Monal S: So this function is doing something internally like this. That's why it is able to return, okay?
Vignesh S: Okay, sir, yeah.
Vignesh S: Yes, thank you.
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: And guys, whoever… yes, thank you very much.
Monal S: And others are asking, I have no doubt. Guys, whoever is having no doubt, feel free to drop off, and please enjoy your weekend, alright? Thank you very much, guys, thank you. See you, bye-bye.
Monal S: Yes, okay.
Monal S: Then we have Avani.
Monal S: I'm gonna go next.
Avni Yadav: Hi, Munel, how are you doing?
Monal S: Hey, I'mning, I'm doing good. How are you?
Avni Yadav: Sorry, the computer name is incorrect. Hey, my question is, we have been going through the previous lectures and the notes that you have provided, along with some of the assignments that we have, and reviewing them. Is there any better way, would you suggest, in terms of reviewing the previous content?
Monal S: See, previous con… whatever content we share, it is always based on what… what we taught in the live session, right? So, what exactly you want to do? You want to do Fast Track?
Avni Yadav: So basically, I'm just trying to fast-track the revision, right? So, I'm already doing it, but it's taking a lot of time just to revise everything.
Monal S: Okay, see, that's why, okay?
Monal S: what I usually suggest to people who are… do you know Python already?
Avni Yadav: No, not a lot.
Monal S: Not a lot, okay? So I will suggest something like, this is our course, right? Let's just go through the course. Whenever you are doing revision and you're also attending the live session, okay? Live classes have a little bit more detail, usually.
Monal S: So… Go to this.
Monal S: First, I will not suggest doing the revision from here, because these classes are pretty large, okay? You are good if you want to watch the previous class resource, it is totally fine. But if you don't want to deal with people asking doubt, or I explaining things in a 3-4 ways, always go to this Python
Monal S: And click on this playlist, and complete Python as fast as possible.
Monal S: Because these are short videos, if you click on this link, you will see these are Krisha's YouTube video, okay?
Monal S: And these are, let's skip it.
Monal S: Let's see how much ours it is.
Monal S: Okay, so here you're able to see this playlist.
Avni Yadav: Yeah.
Monal S: 29 minutes. 19 minutes, 21, whatever topics you feel like you want to learn. Suppose you are learning list and boolean variables. Now, sets dictionaries. Within 16 minutes, you will be able to recap very fast.
Monal S: But, if you want to do recap, there is no faster way to recap directly from our course, that is, from, like… I got you.
Monal S: Okay.
Avni Yadav: Yeah, that's helpful, thank you.
Monal S: That's for sure. Yes, you're welcome.
Avni Yadav: Have a good… have a good weekend, bye-bye.
Monal S: You too, you too. Bye-bye. Thank you.
Monal S: Vijay, you're next?
Monal S: Vijay?
Vijay Kumar: Isa?
Monal S: Hello, baby, Jay. Rough noon.
Vijay Kumar: Sir, my doubt is from the previous class, yesterday's class. Could you please open that, notebook?
Monal S: True?
Monal S: What?
Vijay Kumar: So, the last point that you… Yes, sir.
Monal S: Previous class, yes?
Vijay Kumar: Huh?
Vijay Kumar: Could you please just, move, scroll up?
Vijay Kumar: Sir, this last one.
Monal S: Do you have it written?
Vijay Kumar: I think I've forgotten.
Vijay Kumar: I made my notes, but… Dingo.
Monal S: That's fine.
Monal S: Do you remember what you were not able to understand?
Vijay Kumar: So, could you scroll… scroll somewhat?
Vijay Kumar: But I think, the second last point.
Monal S: Wicked and lost.
Vijay Kumar: Second loss means, at the end.
Vijay Kumar: At the end of this notebook.
Monal S: gone.
Monal S: Or do you want PDF?
Vijay Kumar: Mmm…
Monal S: They want to take some time. In the meantime, I can answer other people. If you have… if you figured it out, just speak up. Is that fine?
Vijay Kumar: Okay, so I, I'll, like, go through and…
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Vijay Kumar: Sure, sure.
Monal S: See, I'm here to help, okay? Understand that we are exactly what facing the issue, let me know, alright?
Vijay Kumar: Yes, sir, sure, sir. Thank you so much.
Monal S: Thanks, Vijay. Yes.
Monal S: Alright, and Vikram, you're next.
Monal S: Makaram?
Vikram: Yeah. So, hi Monu, first of all, yeah.
Vikram: Thank you, the way you are teaching. Actually, I was doing a lot of things from past 14 years. Now, I come to know why we are doing like this. Like, we know what to do, how to do. You are teaching us, actually. So, my question is regarding, the data types. So, basically, my background is from TypeScript. So, in TypeScript, we… we make our function method safe, like, if we talk about the.
Monal S: Very close to how Python looks like, right?
Vikram: Yeah, yeah, yeah. But only difference is, like, when you pass, let's say there is a function, and we have an argument A and B, we can mention A will, A will have a type of string, B will have a type of integer. Now, when user pass that value, there is a security that, you know.
Monal S: We also have in Python. But it is recently introduced. Oh, okay, so the way, till now.
Monal S: In Python, Python is dynamically typed language. It means at the start, like, it's been a lot of years, that Python will dynamically calculate data type of a variable based on the value we provide, and it changes it.
Monal S: But in Python now, there is also a way where you can type the variable which that, the type of that variable, yes.
Vikram: So, are we going to cover that in future…
Monal S: Yes, it is… yes, I will cover, okay?
Vikram: Okay, you are going to go.
Monal S: Where is that? This is all across, right?
Monal S: So, when you are creating values like this, you can write it like end colon A.
Monal S: Something like that, okay? So you will be able to write things.
Vikram: Hmm.
Monal S: Okay, so that is type. This is not exactly, but you will be able to write and dimension this way.
Vikram: Okay, yeah. And the second question, yeah, second question is very basic regarding, again, a function and method. So, in time script, whenever something we write outside the class, we mention it, it, like, export a sync function, then the function name, right? But inside the class, we never use this thing. So this is the same difference we have in Python, like.
Vikram: the… you were mentioning, when… when we have some method in the class, this is the method. When we.
Monal S: I will tell you, okay? Can you just give me a second? I'm just.
Vikram: Because, yes, just keep missing.
Monal S: Sorry about that.
Monal S: I have a lot of things coming today, so…
Monal S: Not ignoring that cause. Are you there?
Vikram: Yeah, yeah, I'm…
Monal S: Yes, okay. So, see, functions inside classes are called as methods, right? Because they share memory, they're a part of it. That's why they call methods, right?
Vikram: Good.
Monal S: Yes. So, functions outside of class is just functions. We can also create a sync function in Python as well.
Vikram: Okay.
Monal S: Yes, yes, there is also a ring.
Vikram: Because there is a concept of synchronous and synchronous in TypeScript, and we have to rarely take care of everything.
Monal S: But for now, what we are doing, because, see, you're in TypeScript, that language is… has to work with Synchronous, because they're communicating with the backend. Python is kind of the backend here, so that's why we are starting here. We can run single-threaded, multi-threaded jobs in a sequence, but there is async also, so we can do that.
Vikram: Okay, we will do… cover this in a little bit.
Monal S: Yes.
Vikram: Sure, thank you, Michael.
Monal S: Thanks.
Monal S: Alright, yes.
Monal S: Hey, Nickel?
Nikhil...: I don' Right now, the screen.
Nikhil...: But, I actually are affiliate, so… Nikki.
Monal S: I'm not able to hear you.
Monal S: Very feeble voices coming.
Nikhil...: I'm now liberation.
Monal S: Still the scheme.
Monal S: Is that all clear, Nikhil?
Monal S: Guys, Rahul is the last person, then we will close the session. It's already 1.40, okay?
Monal S: Okay, I think Nikhil is fixing, but in the meantime, Ashwani? Ashwani?
Ashwani Panwar: Isai Model?
Monal S: Yes, Ashwan, you're not able.
Ashwani Panwar: Yeah, thank you. Thank you, sir. Good afternoon, sir. Sir, I just want to know, sir, as we are preparing for the AI and ML,
Ashwani Panwar: So, in the interview sessions, like, if we got an opportunity.
Ashwani Panwar: So, in that, is DSA… plays.
Monal S: Not on.
Ashwani Panwar: Couldn't ruin.
Monal S: always. Depends on…
Ashwani Panwar: It depends on the…
Monal S: If you're applying to a company where you will be also dealing with a lot of software engineering, then they will ask you DSA. But if you're applying for just AI engineer working on the back end of AI and other things.
Monal S: lot… very few companies will have asked in that. So, you will be, okay to apply without DSA to 80% of the company.
Ashwani Panwar: Okay, sir. And, if we are, like, if we want to prepare for DSA,
Ashwani Panwar: Then, is there any suggestion from you, sir?
Monal S: My answer has a very great Udemy, but for now, I think my answer wants to join, so let's see what Meinxer has to say, okay?
Ashwani Panwar: Yeah, sir, I have one question also.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes.
Ashwani Panwar: So system designing, plays a role in interview for AI and ML?
Monal S: Or senior people.
Monal S: Okay, for senior people, or if you… if you are targeting product-based companies, then they will ask system design.
Monal S: Okay?
Ashwani Panwar: Not, all the companies.
Monal S: Oh, sure.
Ashwani Panwar: Okay, so do we cover deployment?
Monal S: Nice.
Monal S: Deployment will be covered, but not extensively. This course is kind of… if you see the projects, right? Last, if you check the project section of the syllabus in the last, you will see one of the projects is having deployment. So we will slowly increase the level of the project, and the last one will have deployment as well.
Monal S: Okay?
Ashwani Panwar: Okay, yeah, thank you, thank you. This is just a photo. Thank you so much.
Monal S: Thanks. Thanks, Ashley.
Ashwani Panwar: Yeah, bye.
Monal S: Guys, as I mentioned, Rahul is the last one.
Monal S: At the last time, we cannot keep on raising.
Nikhil...: Okay, hi.
Shahul: I'm sorry, it's happened.
Monal S: Hey, hey, Sean.
Shahul: Pretty confusing, no problem. So, first one, yeah, thanks for your patience, you know, explaining things. I just have two quick questions. First one being, in the list, right, we can have different data types, like, you can have integer.
Monal S: Yes.
Shahul: So, one thing what I observed was, when I was just, working out, I had given, like, 007, so it said you can't div…
Monal S: 007 is 7, no? Yeah, so it said, saying, like, you know, preceding you cannot have zeros if you're in terms of office. Yes, yes.
Shahul: So, you know, I was just wondering if some, you know, when we're doing this data clean, what if we have such sort of values?
Monal S: No, no, no, see, when someone is filling data clearing, then we can… we can fix it, okay? Okay.
Shahul: We are going to run a lot of powerful applications. We don't just…
Monal S: Plain Python. We use a lot of libraries meant for data cleaning, so they will be handling all of that, don't worry.
Shahul: Okay, yeah, thanks, thanks, Manas. My second question is regarding the new project, not the live project which you guys launched.
Shahul: which is pretty good, like, you know, I was looking for something like that instead of from Iris or technical prediction. Nice, nice about it. The only thing is I want to know, like, like, once when we finish the ML, like, we have Python stats and machine learning, are we good to, go ahead and enroll for that?
Shahul: Or should we also…
Monal S: After machine learning, after machine learning, but make sure… but I'm telling you beforehand, right? It will be…
Monal S: a little complex to understand at the start, because we are not familiar with projects. After machine learning, if we see big projects all of a sudden, it becomes kind of overwhelming. But that is what we want when we are going to learn projects, right?
Monal S: Or learning is required, but only after machine learning, you're… see, there you have machine learning projects as well. You will not be able to do all projects, but machine learning as well. Only machine learning at the start. Once you cover deep learning, then deep learning projects, once you understand computer vision, then computer vision projects, similar like that, okay?
Shahul: maybe I'll put it forward like this. In case if I complete deep learning, LLM, and everything, I think we are good to go and explore other projects. Yes, we have to put our hard work and hard work that I understand, but we'll be capable enough to understand, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes, for sure.
Shahul: Oh, that's all I had, Monel, and happy weekend to you as well.
Monal S: Thanks, sir. Thank you very much.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Now all this done? Do we have no shower?
Monal S: Raul, you're already done, right?
Monal S: Shall we?
Shahul: Yeah, I'm done, actually. I think you called up my name again, yeah.
Monal S: Alright, sorry about that.
Monal S: Okay, Nikhil, are you still here? Rahul?
Monal S: Okay, guys, I cannot read and speak to people at the same time, okay?
rahul: Hello?
Monal S: Hello? Who is it? Raul? Hello, Raul, yes?
Monal S: Boom.
rahul: Are you able to hear me?
Monal S: Yes, Arun, I'm able to hear you.
rahul: Okay, I… I have a question, like, after when we learn about the transformers.
rahul: Then, like, I'm trying… actually, I'm trying to play with some of the models. So, we will be… once we do this, we'll be able to also, working here in this course, about removing a layer and introducing a layer when we're.
Monal S: But you need to check in the syllabus, okay?
rahul: Actually, I tried, I tried that. They talked about the transformers and deep learning.
Monal S: The transformers, you're not going to create from scratch. We are going to learn the actual transformers, what layers and everything is, but creating from scratch will be done, not just scratch, but we have generative AI courses also coming, right? Transformers is the kind of part of… it's a part of generative AI only.
Monal S: Alright? So there, you will be doing everything like model building, model training, and other things, fine-tuning things. So that is more advanced. Transformers are advanced, rather.
rahul: Okay, okay, because that's what exactly I was, so… is there any specific UDME course that I can panelist staff, which talks about that, and I can look into that?
Monal S: a transfer.
rahul: Oh, God.
Monal S: tuning, I think Udemy course is not there, but team is working on it.
Monal S: So, currently, I will suggest you to wait for generative, or if you want to work, just check with the support team if they have any previous batches where someone taught all of this, okay?
Monal S: So, you can see, you can see the syllabus in Christian Academy, right? Older courses that are also done. If you're interested, you can buy older courses as well, where we have done all of that. So check if that aligns in the syllabus. If not, then let's figure it out something, okay?
rahul: Thank you so much.
Monal S: Sure, sure, Rahul. Thank you.
rahul: Yeah, and one last thing. In some case, when we are practicing, when we are… I'm doing all these transformers, although I'm, like, playing with this, if I have questions or doubts about it, can I reach here and ask, and… I'm just asking about whether I know.
Monal S: Yes, in this course, it will be very hard, and it will… for the mentor who's already in that progress, because we are also working on 5 different things, right?
Monal S: So, for the mentor who is teaching you Transformers will be able to… will be able to help you faster, as compared to me, who is currently here. But when I was teaching Transformers, I will be able to quickly answer you.
Monal S: Yeah, are you able to understand?
rahul: Yes, I got it, I got it.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes, that's all around.
rahul: Thank you so much, Henry.
Monal S: Yes, thank you.
rahul: No, no, I really appreciate it, and I understand that we should be in the context of the time and the flow. So, for that perspective, but definitely, yeah, I will look for the old courses that were completed.
Monal S: Yes, and this has the thing that you already require, yes.
rahul: Thank you so much, really appreciate it.
Monal S: Thanks, Laura, thanks very much.
Monal S: Yes. Bye-bye. And then we have Nikhil. Nikhil?
Monal S: What is a query?
Monal S: Okay, Shrikar, if you're having too many kernels, then select the kernel which you created recently. That's all.
Monal S: It is really possible that you have many kernels, because you created many. Just select the one which is in your folder level. Yes, Nikhil?
Nikhil...: I'll take them yearly.
Monal S: Yes, I can hear you.
Nikhil...: So, I actually taken and produced, AI Power Interpretation and resume pricing. Actually, I didn't know anything about this project. So, till March, I want to deliver that solution. So, can we,
Nikhil...: Can you give me an which essential topic I need for this project?
Monal S: you will see, for you to understand that I don't know AI-powered entry, because you will see that mentor name below it. Yes, Nikhil?
Nikhil...: Yes.
Monal S: directly connect to the mentor on the LinkedIn that, this is something which I require, and I want to understand, can you guide me what topics I'll be requiring for this to learn? Then I will take this project.
Monal S: It will be faster.
Nikhil...: Thank you.
Monal S: Because, yes, that mentor created, right? That will be able to help what technology he used. Or else, give the project architecture to Chad GPT or someone, ask that these are the things, but this is my current stage, guide me, what should I do next?
Nikhil...: Okay.
Monal S: Alright.
Nikhil...: Thank you.
Monal S: Yeah, sure, Nikon.
Monal S: Okay, Milind?
Monal S: Thank you very much, Thomas.
Milind Wayade: Hi, yes, sir.
Milind Wayade: Yes, Mon, sir. I have a doubt. You are teaching in a very best way, but my some advice is…
Milind Wayade: You, you, you, you are teaching a function, or any method, like, okay, so you, you, you are teaching from scratch. But, my advice is, you, you take a problem, basic.
Milind Wayade: to intermediate, and then the difficult one also. So, most… most clarity will be clear then.
Milind Wayade: you are taking a problem intermediate or difficult level, then people will understand some basic concepts or intermediate and difficult level. That's my… some advice as well.
Monal S: Sure, Meerin, I will try to incorporate on this level, so…
Milind Wayade: Please. Please, please, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
Monal S: clinic, thanks.
Milind Wayade: Oh, okay, thank you.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: Shrikar, you are last. Guys, Shrika is last, then we will close the session, okay?
Monal S: Trikar, I'm able to see your issue, I already answered that. Guys, and someone asked that, do you need UV compos… guys, UV is not compulsory. If you're fine with Conda, do with Conda, okay?
Monal S: But, again, you need to learn conduct. It is not just nothing not to learn. Shrika?
sreekar: Hi, sir.
Monal S: If there are too many kernels, select the one which you created recently, or delete all, because you have a lot of them.
Monal S: Alright.
sreekar: How can I… can I save those streams, sir?
Monal S: Well, you can see here.
Monal S: Okay, join as a panelist.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: And Shikar, don't try to create a lot of environments. If you're using it for a project, then keep it.
sreekar: Focus.
Monal S: Delete everything else.
sreekar: Is it visible, sir?
Monal S: It is visible.
sreekar: When I try to… when I try to run this one, it is run successfully.
sreekar: We're gonna close?
Monal S: Can you close .venv? Can you click on that?
Monal S: Can you click on .VENV in your folder structure?
sreekar: this person.
Monal S: Yes, alright, so this level is clear.
Monal S: We are inside level 1, you have VE and V. Okay, can you select a Python 3.12?
Monal S: Can you select… is this your kernel? Correct kernel?
sreekar: Mr.
Monal S: You know, Colonel?
sreekar: This is the one.
Monal S: deselect? Okay, this is… no, no, no, don't select that, don't select that.
Monal S: First click on kernel.
sreekar: Good.
Monal S: Are you able to see .VENV? The third one. In the third one, you can see .env.
sreekar: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Monal S: That is your current kernel.
sreekar: Nope.
Monal S: Can you please run anything? You don't have a lot of environments, you only have .VENV.
Monal S: Kernel failed to start because Python is not available. It means you have not installed it correctly, VNV. Can you delete VENV?
Monal S: Can you delete the folder.v and we delete it? Delete it.
Monal S: Delete this folder.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Can you do UVPython pin 3.12, type in the terminal?
Monal S: UV?
Monal S: Python?
Monal S: PIN, 3.12.
Monal S: V.12.
Monal S: Press enter.
Monal S: Now write UV, V-E-N-V.
Monal S: Then, write some name of the environment.
Monal S: Test one or something.
Monal S: Right? Test underscore 1.
Monal S: Press enter.
Monal S: Alright, now, can you please click on the kernel in your, okay, can you close the VS Code and open up… no, no, don't do that. You don't require that. Close the VS Code, and then open it again.
Monal S: It will ask you to save file because you have not saved, yes?
sreekar: Here's the screen is sharing, sir.
Monal S: Please share away. I'm not able to see your screen.
Monal S: As I can see. Select kernel, select kernel.
Monal S: Now you will see… okay, you're not able to see anything.
Monal S: Can you click on select another kernel.
Monal S: Click on Python Environment.
Monal S: Right.
Monal S: This path one is not correct, okay. And can you open CMD?
sreekar: Hold on CMD.
Monal S: Now, okay, because you are inside Level 1 Test 1, can you please open folder of Level 1 itself?
Monal S: See, currently you have opened a folder of practical.
Monal S: I want you to open level 1 in the folder. No, no, no, no, in the VS Code.
Monal S: In the VS Code.
sreekar: Yeah, this is the low notes.
Monal S: No, you're opening in Terminal. I want… can you see… okay. Can you see on the left side, you opened the folder called as Practical. Can you
Monal S: Level 1?
Monal S: Level 1 instead of practical.
Monal S: Go to File, Go to Final.
Monal S: Shikar, is this your first class?
sreekar: No, sir, I… actually, this is my third class.
sreekar: And listen, I want to…
Monal S: Okay, it's fine. Click on File.
sreekar: Okay.
Monal S: No, no, no, file on top, file on top. Click on file. No, no, no. Very top, there is a file.
Monal S: She can't see this.
sreekar: Oh yeah, okay.
Monal S: Open folder, click on Open Folder.
sreekar: Okay.
Monal S: Now select… go inside practical folder, go inside practical, select Level 1, now select this folder.
Monal S: Click on select this folder.
Monal S: There is select folder. This is what… yeah, don't save, don't save, don't save.
sreekar: workers.
Monal S: Did you wrote anything? No, right?
sreekar: No, sir, no problem.
Monal S: Don't… yeah, don't save.
sreekar: Okay.
Monal S: This is what I wanted you to open.
Monal S: Is this marked yet?
sreekar: Okay, yeah.
Monal S: Here, but you don't have any notebooks, right? Now create inside… why it is showing you test 1?
Monal S: Okay, yeah.
Monal S: Minimize that, minimize that.
Monal S: Where is Level 1?
Monal S: Did you…
sreekar: Can I deliver?
Monal S: what?
Monal S: No, no, don't delete. Click on File again, click on File again.
Monal S: Open folder, Open folder.
Monal S: Go one level back, go one level back.
Monal S: Select on everyone, but just select. One click, single click, and select folder.
Monal S: See, now you're inside level 1, okay? Now click on Notebook, click on Notebook.
Monal S: Click on any of this nodes. No, no, no.
Monal S: Don't… see, never touch this one.
sreekar: Okay, sir, okay, okay.
Monal S: Now, see, detecting kernel it is doing. Click on select kernel.
Monal S: Click on Python Environments, it will show you Test 1. Is it showing you Test 1 on the top?
sreekar: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Monal S: Yeah, click on it.
Monal S: Always select the, your current location, okay? Run it.
Monal S: Install.
Monal S: It will take some time.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: But I think you will not have any issue. It will work.
Monal S: Just wait.
Monal S: See, UV will not be able to, recognize your environment if you're 2-3 folders back. You should be in the same folder as your environment, that is test 1.
sreekar: Question.
Monal S: So, always try to open Level 1.
sreekar: Lucas.
Monal S: Later, when we create Level 2, Level 3, I will show you again.
sreekar: Yes, sir, another question is, if I use this…
sreekar: There is another file… another notebook, 18… 18…
sreekar: If I run it on… if I run this one with the same test run, it will work.
Monal S: Yes.
sreekar: Let's suppose…
Monal S: It will work.
Monal S: No, just don't run it now, because it is installing. Can I go to 17 and run it?
Monal S: And I go to 17, yeah, it is… it is working, yes?
sreekar: too. Yes.
Monal S: Not any second out. Alright, list issues solved.
sreekar: I'm with your service officer.
Monal S: Yes. See, now it will not work because your string is incorrect. Select test 1, select test1 as kernel first.
Monal S: In this 5-day trigger, do a lot of practice, okay?
sreekar: Okay, yeah.
sreekar: Sorry, sir, I was in the crypto shopper model, that is the reason I didn't understand.
Monal S: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine. Whatever is your pace, do it, okay? You have not selected the kernel, but yeah, click on Test 1, click on Test 1, it is already showing you on the top.
Monal S: See, it is already showing you top? Yes, click on it.
Monal S: Now run.
Monal S: Working?
sreekar: Okay, thank you, sir. I got the chat came now.
Monal S: Yes.
sreekar: Thank you very much.
Monal S: Alright, sure. Don't worry, practice a lot, you will be familiar with all of these things.
sreekar: Okay. Okay.
Monal S: honored?
sreekar: Is that correct?
Monal S: much.
Monal S: Love it.
Monal S: Alright guys, so we are done with today's class, and thank you very much for joining in this session.
Monal S: And, yes, thank you very much for giving
Monal S: you're all in this class, alright? Thank you guys, bye-bye. See you.
Monal S: See you on next Saturday.
Monal S: Bye guys, bye.